uh
um
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david hackman's show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is a fan
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
[Applause]
is
and then controlled by the darkness of
david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david hackman
he is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
david
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like because you're
asking bizarre questions you're actually
like an idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate that
all right thank you for coming goodbye
goodbye
[Music]
all men who are progressive
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's just beyond parody i mean massive
dumps cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dump big
obama
obama
[Music]
all right welcome everybody it is
election night it
am i on
obama oh okay now it is on it is on okay
good sorry guys no um there there's um
i'm actually not i'm gonna give you guys
there were some audio issues there
during the intro song something about
the configuration is not exactly the way
it typically would be
because i'm actually not in the studio
right now i'm going to give you guys a
peek behind the curtain
but the truth is the truth is
that as you know
there is a duplicate studio
and this is actually
a green screen
i filmed the empty studio and the way
you can tell is it's a different
microphone let's put the background back
on
um
and uh yeah so as you as as many of you
know we we employ a pretty extensive
security team
uh
mostly mostly mossad
and often on election days they think
it's good for me to be
in the bunker um just because
you just don't know uh glenn glenn
yunkin's followers are pretty whacked
so um they've moved me into the basement
i was here inspecting it earlier it was
only an inspection which i sometimes do
but now i am actually in the bunker
um
so yeah in any case i mean i could even
do the whole thing like this but no
we're gonna do it with i think it it
actually is psychologically distressing
to people when the background is
different
so we're gonna keep the background um on
some of you may have noticed this room
has not been treated in the exact same
it's been treated fine from i mean i'm
not abusing the room i just mean
the audio treatment is not exactly what
we have um at the main site
and thus
some elements of echo you guys are
familiar with echo and reverb right
obama it can happen really to any of us
okay
we have we have
an incredibly explosive race on our
hands here we have results which we can
look at here and we're going to clean
this up for you guys um
let me actually get this all cleaned up
let's see what we got here
this this is not we're kind of doing
this in real time so we're going to
maybe go like this
i want to make sure that the shot is
appropriate for my audience well that's
not what we wanted
let's see here and then we're going to
start getting into here we go
so we'll maybe go like this
i don't even know that we necessarily
need that
and then we'll extend this way
uh
yeah maybe sort of like that i think
that's probably pretty good and the
super chats will be up on the screen
they'll be coming down um
uh
so far just sir you are not the beta
male thanks for all that you and your
staff do i appreciate that
um okay good so i think from a technical
standpoint we're doing it pretty well
here the biggest race tonight that we
are looking at is virginia governor the
the the importance of this race cannot
possibly be overstated
the winner of the virginia gubernatorial
election
will signify either
that republicans are really going to
have to work for it in 2022 or
or
um
that democrats are in trouble
because if we actually look at
uh let's see when would it have been
virginia
gubernatorial election results passed
if you look at the 2017 gubernatorial
race
it was the democratic candidate ralph
northam
by nine points okay that's a strong
democratic win and increasingly oh hold
on a second i'm sorry i'm still getting
the shot all proper
uh let's go this way there we go
and maybe even a little more there we go
okay
um
and there we go
okay probably actually that's not even
really gonna work i'll do the best i can
with it okay um
so
if what we end up having today
is oh and now it's not over on this side
guys we are gonna get the shot right for
you
there we go
dear god
okay i think we've got
it beautiful okay i apologize guys i'm
working working on everything here as we
go
um
if if democrats win but by one meaning
if terry mcauliffe wins but by one
um that's really not great
that's already not great
it already signifies probably to some
degree
a um
a decline from 2017 and obviously if
glenn younkin wins a complete and total
lunatic it is very bad for democrats
looking at 2022. right now we have a
third of the vote in about a million
votes are in
and glenn younkin is up by seven and a
half this is very bad
this is very very bad for democrats with
a third of the vote in we have a whole
bunch of other races that we're going to
be looking at we're going to be looking
at what's on the ballot in 2022 we may
hear some phone calls from you guys if
we get to our 100 members
um
[Music]
let's see if i can just fix
it's a bunch of different things here to
fix
there we go
everything going wrong here
there we go
all right just getting all these shots
properly set up for what's going to be a
very very eventful stream
um
we have a number of different races that
we're going to be looking at and results
are coming in
boston mayoral new jersey gubernatorial
new york city mayoral just so so many
different things
we are going to continue banning people
it appears at a very very steady clip we
had major issues today the just horrible
horrible people showing up today during
the um
kyle rittenhouse stream
just to give you guys some examples i
want to be fair and i unband a bunch of
people
um some examples of things that will get
you banned or won't like for example
coming in now and trolling trump 2020
will get you banned because it's 2021
almost 2022. trump2020 it's just
trolling and we're going to ban you for
it now if you're going to make a first
amendment argument you're an idiot uh
you know you're trolling okay now if you
say trump 2024 and you're not repeating
it in all caps like a lunatic that's
allowed okay trump 2020 there's a
there's a we're evaluating these things
there's a difference between saying
trump 2020 a year and a half or a year
after the guy lost not a year and a half
year after the guy lost
that's different than saying i would
like trump to win in 2024 okay so that's
not a ban
free kyle like the kyle rittenhouse
stuff
that's a ban okay now i think kyle is
not guilty is not a ban and so i want to
make sure that the moderators and i that
everybody's on the same page you're
allowed to say you believe kyle will be
not guilty or even that he is not guilty
we have a trial going on to determine
that okay so free kyle trolling that's a
ban
and i think kyle is not guilty not a ban
and then i want to get your thoughts on
this my instinct is let's go brandon is
an instagram because it's just idiotic
trolling i don't like it i don't like
seeing it in the chat it just distracts
from substance what do people think
about let's go brandon i did ban two
people before the stream even started
for let's go brandon
perma band people are saying
yeah
yeah i think let's go brandon just needs
to be a band basically for the most part
okay
all right so that's uh that's what's
going on as far as that goes and we're
keeping a really really close eye
on this election here where it is still
seven and a half seven and seven point
four percentage points glenn younkin as
of right now is running away with this
thing
okay and there are some early results
from fairfax county
only a third of the vote there that
could be good
for terry mcauliffe these areas closer
to washington dc arlington 80 to 20 to
four to one
37 so these are high population areas
terry mcauliffe needs these areas
loudoun county fairfax prince william
and arlington absolutely crucial
um as you can see as you get you know
further south and west it becomes sort
of like west virginia
but remember that a lot of these places
have very very few voters so for example
lee county has 80 in it's only six
thousand votes
dickinson county has seventy percent in
it's only three thousand votes buchanan
has basically the whole thing isn't it's
only six thousand votes whereas when you
look over here we're talking about this
is only a third and it's already a
hundred and thirty three thousand votes
uh when you look at loudoun this well no
loud and loud is not a good example um
43 000 votes but that's only 28 so this
is where terry mcauliffe needs votes and
we're going to be monitoring those areas
very very closely let's just take a tour
of what else we have today
in the state of florida
there is
a democratic primary that doesn't mean
much to me i don't know much about this
race there's also a republican primary
it has already been awarded to jason
mariner the miami florida mayor's race
is a very interesting race
francis suarez is the incumbent was
expected to win and is running away with
it
okay st petersburg florida hialeah
florida these are not
hugely significant no offense to anybody
they're not hugely significant races we
have a georgia state house district
atlanta georgia mayor is interesting and
that's one that we are going to be
watching as the results start coming in
i believe now as as the uh we are at the
stroke of 8 p.m
on the east coast
in kentucky
there's a state senate race of some
interest but it doesn't really mean too
much to us in some state house races
up in maine there's a state house race
massachusetts has the very interesting
boston mayoral going on and then some a
couple state house races michelle wu who
is one of the mayoral candidates in
boston follows me on twitter we've
exchanged some very nice messages and i
have said you know informally i like
michelle wu
and i think she's going to win
i think michelle is going to win and
we're going to have a david pakman show
um element
in the boston mayoral which i think is
which i think is great uh there are some
races in michigan state senate the
detroit mayor mike
duggan is running he's the incumbent
we're going to be looking at that
results expected maybe not until nine
there
minnesota
minneapolis mayor
ranked choice voting first place st paul
mayer
so we've got that going on
i see the hype train we're going to
address it momentarily mississippi
you've got state senate stuff i don't
know how interesting that will be to us
in new jersey you've got the mayor of
durham okay
new jersey is in north carolina rather
in new jersey new jersey governor is a
big race phil murphy is the incumbent
democrat he is up for uh re-election and
we're expecting to start getting some
votes in there very soon there's also
new jersey state senate
um
in new mexico the mayor of albuquerque
is on the ballot
in new york new york city mayor is on
the ballot this is a big big deal
very very strong powerful deal we're
going to be um
we're going to be looking at that
buffalo mayor in a senate state senate
race
in ohio
we have the congressional district 11 it
has already gone to chantal brown over
laverne gore overwhelming victory there
we also have congressional district 15
which is a fight cincinnati ohio mayor
toledo mayor and cleveland mayor some
interesting local races there
in the state of pennsylvania
state house and pittsburgh mayor so
we'll be looking at that
in rhode island it's a state senate race
i i to be honest because of our audience
we're probably not going to pay too much
attention to some of these state
uh state senate and state rep races
back to virginia with 34 in the vote
total really slowing down now we're
still stuck at this 1.03 million votes
in glen younkin is ahead still very very
early there and lastly in the state of
washington the mayor of seattle
washington is up so we're gonna mostly
for now keep an eye on virginia i'm
expecting some more votes there but but
as more things keep coming in we are
going to be looking at them and we have
a number of different things we're
looking at
we have abc news live stream
let's listen in from the yunkan
headquarters
we've spoken to a lot of people here on
the ground and it's really unclear how
those endorsements influenced their
decision a lot of the voters that we
spoke to said that it wasn't this race
isn't about
those the president all right so we're
watching that uh we also have cbs news
coverage looking right now at loudoun
county let's listen to what is being
said take a quick edge or if it's a mix
if it's more election day which would
mean not maybe the republican takes an
edge or
maybe mcauliffe is doing pretty well
at turning out his face of voting i have
to tell you i've never heard it
pronounced mcauliffe
so let's shift our attention ever so
briefly to new jersey yeah the polls
have just closed there
any data yet so far to look at let's
take a look um i'm going to go back to
the new jersey map and the answer is
okay so we're watching that we are
monitoring newsmax just to see what's
being said
um
we just want to see what's being said
attorneys to stand by
in case of a call of loss
this is where the democrats always beat
the republicans this is this is stink
field like grant stinkfield or something
like that board houses with high priced
attorneys right now i'm being told there
are no signs of any sizable republican
army of attorneys which leaves me asking
why not okay so that's going on um we
have video ready to go uh for glenn
younkin's event fox news is covering
glenn young's event also in an hour meet
the press election night special is
going to get going we've got the
decision desk hq
the lead has grown for yunkan another
seven percent of the
um uh ballot
was uh dumped in
and what happened sorry big massive
dumps and with another 10 another three
seven percent of the ballots glenn
younkin is now leading by 10.5 this is
starting to get out of reach folks
democrats may be about to lose virginia
lose virginia
suggesting that 2020 could be an insane
bloodbath
an insane bloodbath so we're looking at
that
um some folks have suggested i keep an
eye on dave wasserman's tweets
let's see what the latest
loudoun county
up to 128 000 votes counted mcauliffe
winning by 5347 mcauliffe better hope
for a huge showing in the remaining
uh
bbm
what's vbm
vote by mail sorry okay
um right now i'd rather be junking but
we've still got a long way to go nine
minutes ago said dave wasserman dave
wasserman is very very good at calling
these elections so we're going to be
following him really
really really closely
i do want to thank everybody who came
out tonight for this stream
and i i can't tell you how much i
appreciate it a few people that i do
want to recognize
are
real-time fan caspa jerry anthony live
two to say
lord curonavirus
sir rock and i lizzy
seven people grabbing twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 50 i also
want to make sure everybody knows
we are bringing out the big guns tonight
the coupon code is felony 21 on my
website the code is so extreme
it's so vile
it's so immoral it should be criminal
three attorneys general right now
looking to criminalize this coupon code
that i can't even tell you how big the
discount is i'm just calling it a big
discount but i would love it if you went
to my website joinpakman.com and use the
code felony21 to get a membership every
one of you will get a thank you from me
it's so important that we continue to
support uh independent media that we
believe in if you hate me don't do it i
mean a lot of you are just trolling
through some of you will be banned some
won't depends on your behavior
but um if you do like what we do
it's really uh something i would
encourage you to do as the lead has now
grown
to
or no it is not okay it is not let's
check in on the massachusetts uh the
boston mayoral to see if we have any
results none yet still awaiting results
there keeping an eye on new jersey as
well
uh early numbers
very strongly going to the incumbent
phil murphy although it's only two
percent of the vote but widely expected
to do well is phil murphy it's new
jersey
not
challenged in the way that virginia is
challenged
um people asking about the buffalo
new york mayor's race
let's see if we have any data there
um buffalo mayor
is there is it even a race is it it's
india walton versus just write-ins that
doesn't seem very competitive i don't
know anything about this race
is it basically that's it
india walton could lose to write-ins
that doesn't sound good man i know very
little about that there's a huge
write-in candidate okay yeah i just
haven't been following buffalo
okay good
um
all right so so there's a lot going on i
think needless to say is the uh is the
point here 41
uh yunkan
tightening by about half a point now
from about 10.5 to just 10.
10-point lead but a 10-point lead is big
um
some of these
wow
uh
arlington
fairfax city okay there's still a lot of
votes to be counted a lot of votes to be
counted and dave wasserman continuing to
tweet about it
radford mcauliffe needed to win by point
three and yonkin won so this is
really bad see this is exactly the type
of thing
that signals bad
uh hold on let's see if i can get us
some more of the top here
there we go
as you can see here radford a college
town in southwestern hold on what are we
even doing
there we go
mcauliffe needed to win by 0.3 and young
can won by nine that's a disastrous sign
that's an absolutely disastrous sign
folks asking about pennsylvania let's
take a look at what's happening there uh
nothing other than in pittsburgh early
very early the democratic candidate is
ahead but that's with zero percent repo
reporting just the first 22 000
so um
that's very very early extremely early
we're going to continue watching all of
these i want to say thank you to
jen here pocket b siam double and kaboom
for signing up via twitch prime i really
appreciate that also people dumping in
memberships on my website i want to say
thank you to mike saltz for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
felony21 thanks to kevin gouldy for the
new membership michelle brillhart has
signed up and so has jennifer lane very
much appreciate that putting us at 58.
uh we will open phone lines if we get to
100 and i think that that would be a
really great thing to do let's see
what's on people's minds
um i want to answer some questions via
super chat always welcome super chats
coming in scott taggart asks sir do you
pronounce it data
data
or
dada i don't even know the third
pronunciation
i am
i tend to say data
the lg
says david why did we run a former
governor who was never that popular
these are good these are reasonable
questions
nina says first year in new area in
virginia tried to vote but the place was
not wheelchair accessible should have
planned better yes my understanding is
there were widespread absentee ballots
mailing
what time should we expect the big dumps
trump loves yeah this is trump's view of
what happened in november of 2020 big
massive dumps sorry no hold on this is
it and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
uh saying congratulations political
people congratulations sir you just won
the election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps right uh in michigan and
pennsylvania
and uh uh all over uh if you if you take
a right so that's
trump's understanding
of what happened in 2020 and we will
keep an eye on what exactly it is that
is happening today the lg says i live in
portsmouth hello to my virginia family
looks like hampton roads is staying to
norms portsmouth d norfolk d newport
news d hampton d chesapeake
watch virginia beach it's the biggest
swing area elaine luria won it by 500
votes in 2018. where is virginia beach i
would guess it's on the beach
let's see here
north umberland westmoreland is it down
here hampton city oh virginia beach city
well it's plus 18 for glenn younkin
right now so that doesn't bode
particularly well
does not bode particularly well based on
that i live in virginia beach i didn't
think it was that red yeah
uh thank you for keeping the chat clean
i don't even live in the u.s and this
makes me sweat sir you should visit
australia someday i would love to
i would love to visit australia so
it's on a list let's put it that way
it's on a list
huge thank you to james fort for signing
up on my website as well as alan
sherrill
and lastly i want to say thank you to
peter sharkey everybody using the coupon
code felony21 guys
it's just check your local laws
there are some more kind of conservative
leaning municipalities that hate coupon
codes this crazy
so just make sure it's legal the coupon
code doesn't violate hipaa but it may
violate other laws and that is uh
problematic
let's listen to what's being said here
step back and be objective here is there
anything at all that you might have done
differently if you were running
lindsay
we've done this before
step back objectively on election night
and the former governor is not possible
listen i think i think that's up that's
up i don't want to take that away from
you guys you guys can you can speculate
i think terry's one terry brings
enormous energy to everything he does
did he just call him jerry oh god or did
he say terry
i think he recognized there was a bit of
a gap but what was smart about his
campaign he recognized that a number of
weeks ago
he said
the turnout game the greyhound game the
number of early voters we were afraid we
might not hit a million we hit a million
two again
into the day we'll see how this all
plays out but i feel very good so
basically he would have done nothing
differently even if mcauliffe loses by
12. the latest updates here
with now 47 percent in are that glenn
young is still up by 10 points now
of course we're still looking there's
areas where we have no votes
there's areas where we have gotten no
additional votes that are good areas for
terry mcauliffe so fairfax is good for
mcauliffe only 37 and it's been stuck
there for a while
um
prince william
stuck at 28.
uh albemarle good for mcauliffe stuck at
18. so
it's it's not over but what you have to
understand is
the more of the vote that's in now at 47
the more overwhelming mcauliffe's margin
needs to be in that remaining 53 percent
in order to win so you we could get to a
i'm making this up okay folks i'm i'm
making this up okay uh please
we could get to a point where we might
have say 57 in
and um
glenn youngen might be winning by 10.
and at that point it would be like okay
to take the lead back mcauliffe needs 62
percent of what's left and then we would
say
that doesn't seem super likely or we
might say that's perfectly likely i
might say it's perfectly likely
um
so that that's what that's what we're
looking at let's take a spin around some
different places you know i want to give
us a little more padding here
uh
on this there we go
there we go
just wanted a little more padding there
so that we could see here
let's get back to new jersey briefly
uh philip murphy now with three percent
reporting holding a two to one lead
expected to do well
let's see if we have any new york city
mayoral results not yet we may not get
them till 9 pm i don't actually know
we'll be here watching
but i don't um
i don't actually know
what is going on with my graphics here
are these okay
i think something's up with my graphics
guys i'm not going to lie
something very very weird
there we go
having a hard time understanding like
something something's just strange
i'm gonna have to look at that later
um okay so new york city mayor we've got
nothing yet
and then in massachusetts nothing yet
with boston mayor but we're looking at
that
we're looking at that let's just see
yeah see how some something's weird here
the heck is going on
and what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna copy the exact settings
let's just paste them here
i'm feeling much better about that i
think we just fixed it
i think we just fixed yeah that was
getting that was getting really weird um
okay so let's just make sure we've got
the virginia numbers and let's get back
to some of the news coverage that is
going on chris christie here will be
commenting uh maybe he will explain why
he supported trump and back in 2009 in
new jersey how much does the national
mood influence the outcome in this
off-year election and how much does it
come down to the candidates and how
they've run their campaigns
i think it comes much more down to the
candidates than it does uh to national
mood now national mood can create a wind
either at your back or in your face and
i think what we've seen in virginia in
particular is that the negative
negativity towards president biden uh in
virginia is is impacting terry mcauliffe
a bit tonight and may uh may impact him
even more as the night goes on but so
people are asking whether i see virginia
as a bellwether
for 2022
i do
i do and and i know that not everybody
in the audience is on the same page on
this
but i i do this was a race that was plus
nine for ralph northam in 2017.
and if it flips i mean guys
you all know i don't blow smoke anywhere
i think smoking's bad i just think it's
bad for your lungs but i'm particularly
not gonna blow smoke
you know where if this goes from
democrat plus nine
to republican plus 10 that's a 19 point
swing
that's a disaster for democrats
it's just it's just a disaster
like even if mcauliffe wins by one and
they hold the governor's house
it's still not a good sign like
democrats are in trouble
democrats are in major trouble
and it's you know every people it's like
there's a lot of kill the messenger i've
found in this in this business i'm in
um it's very very bad and if it goes
young yunkin plus 10 it's it's a
disaster
it's a complete and total disaster um
we're going to keep an eye on a few
different things here
um news let's just out of curiosity
let's see what newsmax's coverage is
real quick just not to cut you off here
but we don't have a lot of time i want
to i want to talk chesterfield county
for a second as well glenn younkin with
about a uh a 10-point lead in
chesterfield county what does that tell
you
good sign
yeah that's the one we've lost the last
couple cycles in a row for him to win
chesterfield i expect a repeat of
virginia beach okay um this is the
youngkin event let's see what's going on
an important factor to their vote this
time around now president biden's marks
on the national economy are negative 54
disapproved so we'll see how much there
is a link between the democratic
candidate terry mcauliffe what accent is
that where they say negative like i say
negative where is negative from great to
see you tonight for that summary
so the issue that has affected every
american is going to start to affect our
politics in a very big way is the
question of scarcity why can't you buy
things that you horse country nay very
nicely very nice
the supply chain is broken what does
that mean exactly well mike taylor is
one of the few people who knows what it
does mean and can explain it he's one of
the owners of combined energy services
we're happy to have them on tonight mike
thanks so much for coming on is this
tucker carlson's voice like what are we
listening to here i don't even
understand
what does that mean and how long till
it's fixed
well talk right off i can really answer
when it's going to be fixed but i can
tell you all right so that's that and
then meet the press starting up very
very soon so we're going to be watching
that very closely keeping an eye here on
the virginia results sort of stuck at 47
stuck at 47 percent there
um and we're uh we're gonna watch that
increasingly closely i do want to say a
huge thank you to rob squared epic
spawner skittle stew and badness for
signing up with twitch prime
really really appreciate that uh we have
not breached the thousand twitch subs
number for a while and it's mostly my
fault because i haven't been streaming
enough it would be an incredible thing
to do that today i also want to thank a
bunch of people signing up on my website
anthony patron just signed up using the
code um felony 21. simba
vuma i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly simba mabuma signing up with
coupon code felony 21. john lair
and cindy harris new members
also robert archer taking advantage of
this ungodly coupon code and putting us
at 70 today
um
people uh oh
check on dave wasserman yeah let's see
what's uh what's up with dave wasserman
okay
danville mcauliffe needed to win by 10
won by only seven that's not good
culpepper yunkan needed to win by 30 won
by 34.
not good for terry mcauliffe louden
county mcauliffe lead up 55-44 with mail
ballots reporting per my benchmarks
mcauliffe needed to win by 14 only
winning by 11. so essentially what dave
wasserman is saying is that every
indicator
every
uh area every precinct or every county
at least we would say
is not looking as good as it's supposed
to look if mcauliffe is ultimately going
to cover this but we're still at 47
percent
still at 47
and there are still many many votes to
be counted here i do know that there are
a lot of trolls everywhere on youtube
and twitch tonight i don't know if there
are that many on facebook just because
of the nature of how facebook works
although it can get pretty pretty toxic
there uh but we're gonna be we're we're
monitoring all of it
very very closely let's take a look at
the elections upcoming in 2022
uh but we want hold on we want united
states
here we go
okay
so in 2022 let's pull this out and then
move it
here
and then
that
there we go
so what's going on in 2022 there are 34
senate elections
in 2022
light blue are democratic incumbents
light red are democratic republican
incumbents
and then dark red are retiring
republicans those are interesting seats
i mean pennsylvania
a very interesting one where there's a
retiring republican that's an
opportunity
for democrats north carolina potentially
as well this is ohio right here
so there are some possibilities there
39
gubernatorial elections guys 36 states
have gubernatorial elections in 2022.
i'm told there's more more nonsense from
dave wasserman no more insight he's
actually really really good
it's over guys
it's over
dave wasserman has called it
i've seen enough
younkin defeats terry mcauliffe in the
virginia governor's race
this is a disastrous
sign for democrats in 2022
from d plus 9 in 2017
to r plus
a lot in 2021
very bad sign
it's over guys it has been called a
major major race
now with 52 percent in still plus 10 and
a half roughly for glenn younkin dave
wasserman has called it
dave wasserman has called it now
this is not an opportunity to start
trolling the chat on twitch or youtube
we're still gonna keep banning people
okay you may be happy about the results
but you're just you're still gonna just
be someone who got banned on the
internet which is a very childish thing
to have happen um let's see if any of
the networks call it
um
cbs has not called it abc has not called
it nbc hasn't even started coverage
and newsmax um
newsmax apparently has not
has not called it
i want to say thank you to mercutio head
nando
the clay catastrophic failure dinosaur
cal
hydraulisk gaming
for signing up via twitch prime putting
us at 74. also welcome everybody signing
up on my website including the great
lauren posey
and wendy van hove
signing up at joinpakman.com both taking
advantage of the coupon code felony21 i
uh we are doing a lot of live streaming
this week we've got the kyle rittenhouse
trial have been streaming that every day
we've got the election results etc i i
invite you and i would really appreciate
it if you signed up on my website it's a
very small ask with this coupon code
it's cheap and i'll thank everybody like
for example stephanie nybert
who just signed up using the code
we never understand why our audience in
general is like 70
male as is the case for many shows like
mine
during live streams we get a ton of
women signing up for membership i don't
know what it is about the live streams i
really don't
let's look at some of the recent super
chats dexi says not just 2022
this is a disaster for virginians
yeah
we have we have employees in virginia
and they are uh
they are on the left i don't think it
would
come as a shock to you
to hear that
thanks mansion and cinema democrats
inability to get anything done in
congress has done a lot to poison the
well we look incompetent as a party yeah
as many of you know i'm not a democrat i
don't care about the democratic party to
the extent that there are better options
in the democratic party than the
republican i support the democratic
party candidates in individual elections
um
but it's not uh
the mansion thing is actually not
trivial i do think
that joe manchin
will be
less likely less likely
to work with democrats given the results
here people disagree with me you can let
me know but i do think that that is
absolutely the case now in terms of
whether this counts as a win for trump
you know trump recently put out a
statement saying or not a statement he
actually let's see if we can find
the see if i can find the clip this was
trump pirro youngkin
trump saying he endorsed if i endorse
somebody they win
if i endorse somebody they win i think
i'm 148 in two now that's a lie about 65
of trump's endorsements win and there's
a bias to success because he mostly
endorses incumbents so it's like it's
not really a great record
that's a pretty good number you endorsed
junkin
and i did endorse younkin and we're
going to see i hope it's not going to be
three okay do you understand that i did
i endorse him strongly looking at that
very strongly yeah so here's the thing
if junkin would have lost trump would
have said
i endorsed him but he he didn't embrace
my endorsement that's why he lost
since junkin we believe has won as
called by dave wasserman
um trump will take credit for it of
course
of course
let's see if he said anything else yeah
no dave wasserman not not taking that
back
and we're continuing to look at these
results
now with 52 in
here we go i do want to see whether we
have any numbers in from the new york
city mayoral yet nothing we may not get
them until nine
and no numbers in from the boston
mayoral we may be waiting a half hour
for those that may be new jersey still
looking very good for the incumbent
democrat phil murphy now winning by more
than a two to one margin more than two
to one
um and we'll keep looking at other races
throughout the evening pennsylvania is
one people asked about although two
state house races and then pittsburgh
mayor so far um stuck with zero percent
reporting just a few votes edward gainey
the democratic candidate is in
uh the lead as of this point in time
but uh virginia called by dave wasserman
and we're gonna see let's see how uh cbs
is talking about it even though dave
even though dave wasserman's called it
also is behind this is i'm going to show
you full transparency here this is one
of our decision desk models where is
this vote headed when everything is
counted at the moment it still looks
headed if marginally for yonket and so
that sort of confirms my thinking right
now that we're going to describe this is
leaning younken and the other point i
want to make we've been talking about
i'll pick a county loudon here all night
this is where the counted vote is for 55
44 macau okay he's winning it but if i
show you that comparison to the 2020
presidential would biden get he got more
he got 61. it's those kinds of
comparisons of mcauliffe against biden
that we're going to be looking at as the
nightmares i mean remember dave
wasserman already called it for yunkan
and says it's over
so you know how much this really matters
now uh i don't know i want to say a huge
thank you to may rican for signing up
via twitch prime also thanks to badness
for gifting two subs over on twitch i
really appreciate that also thank you to
michelle and graham denton sharing a
membership that's allowed
that's allowed michelle and graham
denton signing up on my website
same with lisa bishop signing up with
the coupon code elements of bathrooms
new members number 81 and 82 today uh
very much appreciate that few other
super chats
uh that i missed before
do you believe that if mcauliffe loses
it speaks to the democratic strategy of
tying republican candidates to trump
rather than focusing on policy
differences there was some of that but i
i don't know that i would say that
definitively
carla says i feel like the republicans
are the floppers that play in the nba
especially when they say they can't
breathe when wearing masks
okay
nails by sherry asked do i think yunkan
distancing from trump helps him i think
the exit polls will give us an idea of
that i haven't looked at those
same question came in from bay photo
um
yeah all good points
all good points and and important points
number of years and the question is has
anything changed and the answer is yes
it has things have changed and i get the
point to at least two things number one
i think that parents all across virginia
and in the suburbs are frustrated but
the idea that the democrats don't think
that these the parents should be
involved with school children they don't
like the fact that there have been
sexual assaults in places like loudoun
you know what's really crazy about the
people saying
um we gotta vote for glenn younkin
because we don't like what's being
taught in school
it goes against their principle of
leaving government out of
stuff
to say
we want the governor
to come in
and to tell schools what to teach
like that's
it's against their stated principles
which of course mean almost nothing to
them i played this clip on my earlier
stream but i'll play it for you guys
here this was an interview done in
virginia
issue in the governor's race here in
virginia
hold on
what's the most important issue in the
governor's race here in virginia getting
back to the basics of teaching children
not teaching them critical race theory
and uh and what is critical race theory
well i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it because i don't
understand it that much but it's
something that i don't
the what little bit that i know i don't
care for and and what have you heard
that you don't well i don't i'm not
gonna
you know
i don't uh
don't i don't have that much knowledge
on it but it's something that we could
tell i'm not that i don't care for he
doesn't know much about it
but he definitely doesn't like it that
he can tell you
for sure
that he can tell you for sure
uh okay
let's see what the latest official
numbers are yeah so
i i know that some of you are telling me
that uh
cnn says there's a long way to go
i don't know that dave wasserman is ever
premature in his calls and he has called
it
but um
it's pretty clear that you know when you
go from 34
to 60
in and you're still 10 and a half points
back
the numbers don't look good
it's just you know
intuitive math i think tells us that i
want to say thanks to dan j blue for the
twitch sub really appreciate that my
friend also thank you to matthew
schumacher for signing up on my website
with the coupon code felony21
it's such a big discount
it should be illegal
but it's not
uh love the show keep up the good job
says mark fillion thank you mark
still alive says hi david just got done
watching the latest tyt episode
and feeling doomer about the future how
can i feel more optimistic do you feel
either way so i'm i'm sort of um
i'm i'm not particularly optimistic
about the political future of the united
states and i'm going to say something
that a lot of people
might uh
might might find
i don't know what the word is you might
people might not like me for saying that
hold on i've got to ban a few people
guys i'm sorry
we just have so many people needing to
be banned here
uh
okay so thank you
um
i am trying to basically worry about
what i can worry about
what i can influence or decisions i can
make and so it's very unlikely that
anytime in the next decade or longer
states like south dakota are going to
turn around politically or
mississippi or it's just not very likely
so i'm trying to focus on
staying engaged in the blue states to
which i have a connection
where and and i know some this is where
people some people are going to get
pissed off
where
the standard of living is equivalent to
countries like norway and sweden right i
mean you look at let me see if i can let
me see if i can find this
let's see how to search for this
hdi ranking u.s states compared to
countries this may be shocking to some
people
okay
so the reality is that this is a bad
thing in the sense that i want things to
be good for everybody okay
but there's um an index
called
the human development index
okay
and what this article does
is it compares
the human development index which is
usually done by countries it does it by
state
and it compares it to countries so for
example the hdi in massachusetts is
equivalent to norway
the hdi in connecticut
and minnesota is equivalent to countries
ireland and switzerland
you look at the states of new jersey new
hampshire colorado
and they have an hdi
equivalent to iceland hong kong and
germany you know good places to live
and then there's a very different story
at the bottom right
uh you look at mississippi
and it has an equivalent hdi to andorra
you look at west virginia and it has an
hdi equivalent to
lithuania not a terrible place right
it's not you know it's not a place with
with the level of poverty and whatever
is like equatorial guinea for example
um so the the truth is i'm trying to
focus
on i i'm not going to be able to change
this i'm just one guy right i can
advocate for policies that would improve
this
but i'm trying to also do what i can
uh
to make decisions that that are good for
me at the end of the day in terms of
these states that are here everybody's
got to make decisions about what's best
for them so i'm not optimistic about all
of this this is this is terrible this is
really really bad down here okay
um i i would even question whether
louisiana and esto i've been to estonia
quality of life seems pretty freaking
good in estonia
i i think i would take estonia over
louisiana
just my opinion but what can you do
um
all right nbc news about to get going
newsmax has not yet called this the
young let's listen to the yunkan party
prices are rising okay they seem to be
listening to fox news
uh decision desk has still not called
the race but there is 60 in
oh let's look at some other races okay
so
um
let's look at new york
nothing
nothing yet we've got nothing from the
india walton raised buffalo new york
we've got nothing from new york city
mayor i expect we're going to start
getting those at 00 9 pm in about 20
minutes and then boston mayoral another
interesting one nothing nothing in yet
okay
i'm told that now decision desk has
called virginia
there it is
decision desk hq
has called virginia for the republican
glenn younkin as you and i also know uh
about uh how long ago was it
16 minutes ago 16 minutes ago dave
wasserman called virginia dave wasserman
believes it will be closer than this
right now we are at
plus 10 for yunkan
dave wasserman believes it will
eventually be only a two to five percent
win for yunkan so we're going to
obviously keep watching it as the
results keep coming in but it is now
starting to be called in more and more
places for the republican glenn younkin
i want to say thank you to just an
internet tourist b devlin and andrew
dale
listen to this my friends andrew dale
has been subscribed on twitch for 26
months that's our entire time on twitch
we started on twitch in august
of 2019 we are 26 and a half months in
andrew dale's been subscribed for 26 of
them uh thanks to the three of you
very much appreciate that
also huge thank you to sean moriarty for
signing up on my website
thanks to mark elliott
thanks to claudia benson devin spadey
and ron white all of whom have signed up
on my website using the coupon code
felony21 if you're wondering dave phil
david what are you felony what are you
talking about uh joinpakman.com
felony21
to discount code and people are loving
it greg mckay just used that very same
coupon code and his new member number 93
today 93. people asking what website
this is this is decision desk hq
you do need a free account
in order to look at all this stuff
okay so virginia has been called
let's see how new jersey is looking
new jersey has not yet been called about
a two to one lead for the incumbent
democrat phil murphy with just eight
percent of the vote in so we're going to
keep watching that
and we'll watch the virginia numbers
although it is now starting to be called
it's starting to be called now
so that is uh that's what's going on
there
other super chats coming in sin soo
says i agree with you about the probable
bleak outlook for the united states for
me at 74 years old it makes me sad i
will probably not live to see a brighter
future for the country as a whole i
don't know that i will either
you know it's it's it's grim we have a
lot of
i hate to say it
we have a lot of real ignorance in this
country
and we have a retrograde culture in much
of the country
we have um
i mean it's
it's not good
frank laturco says mcauliffe is terrying
this country apart wow
do you think this loss will mean a
bigger effort to get through the build
back better agenda in the near term i
think it'll mean more difficulty in
getting through the build back better
agenda actually
brian tyler cohen has a don't be a mitch
fund that helps turn districts purple
districts blue
i didn't know if you know about it i
don't
devin s says thank you for pronouncing
my name right my pleasure i do i do the
best i can with names
there are some doozies
uh but i do the best i can
i'm getting an alert that there's 420
people browsing my website right now
that that's got to be a glitch right
there's no way that that's the case
we did up we did a lot of bandwidth
elements
in order to keep things going stronger
um
if you're just joining us we are 15
minutes from when i believe
i believe
we are going to get results from
boston mayoral
and new york city mayoral that's coming
at the top of the hour
so i am very glad
that you are uh joining me today
because we are going to get those
momentarily
um so it was janine pirro
we did this oh yeah i had let me see if
i can find i had some other
there were some other interviews with
virginia voters that were pretty pretty
dystopian
um
no these aren't from today
there were some interviews with voters
in virginia today that i wanted to play
and i am not finding them
virginia
voter let's see
oh yeah here it is okay check this out
um this is very interesting
virginia democratic voter tells fox news
host martha mccallum younger kids just
aren't being taught critical race theory
like the entire the entire gist of it is
just a lie take a listen to this this is
good i see a lot of learning going on
and that greatly concerns me
i think there was a lot of learning loss
uh over the past year and a half we all
saw um with the kids at home and a lot
of these options that you can get
through the class with just a pass or a
fail um and some of the measures that
have sort of watered down uh the
standards in not just in virginia many
places but uh mara brooke thank you very
much it's great to see one thing
i don't think people necessarily uh
truly understand what critical race
theory is younger children are not being
taught critical race theory they can't
understand critical race theory they're
being taught history
that sounds very dangerous so when
somebody here in loudoun county i
understand was upset that his second
grade child was taught that christopher
columbus
killed many indigenous people that's
part of history that is what christopher
columbus did
so i have a hard time i think
kids have to learn history the good the
bad the ugly do we know that columbus
killed people
i've never actually heard that before so
i like that she's saying they're not
being
he did he personally killed people
i just hadn't heard
did columbus murder people
hmm
seems to be uh
it's unclear
some things say yes some things they
know
all right
so i don't think anybody's against that
i think we have to do a fact check on
the christopher columbus story as well
but um uh you know it critical race
there i think sometimes is a little bit
of a misnomer because what's happening
is that there's sort of a reformed
thinking and approach to history that
teaches that the country was founded in
racism you can say critical race theory
is like a legal theory that is found
more in colleges um so maybe giving it
that label has has thrown some people
off but it doesn't mean that there's not
things being taught that are teaching
kids that they're sort of inherently um
you know victims or oppressor so there's
martha mccallum's view
i guess
on uh on on critical race theory
uh republican voter hurls the n word at
volunteers i'm not gonna play that
i'm not gonna play that because that
could be a problem
we already played this one
so we're not going to go over that again
um here's a virginia voter speaking to
msnbc
the important issues this year was uh
education schools the the issues that
are going on in schools right now the
biggest issue is what we're doing about
uh the pandemic i believe mcauliffe hurt
himself a lot with saying parents had no
place to talk about education that hurt
him a lot
and that took away my support
okay
um
here's a third voter saying she voted
for terry mcauliffe
if junkin was to become governor i just
don't know what would happen to virginia
i would really not like to see it turn
red
i would like to keep the democrats in
power
and then here is another voter mom and
independent voting republican why she'll
tell us you're a swing voter yeah i'm a
swing voter i'm the person that
politicians sort of love and hate yeah
i'm sort of clueless about the fact that
there is no similarity whatsoever
between these two parties and so i just
kind of go back and forth and try to get
attention dana jackson whose daughter is
now in high school is an independent
she's voting republican this year and
she sees others like her i have some
friends that are democrats who have
never voted right in their life
and this time they voted every red box
they could find
very weird
couple more interviews here i'll be
voting for glenn yankin on november 2nd
and education is the top issue i think
that virtual schools didn't do any kids
any favors i think that's it's really
important for in school it's funny
because like the virtual schools were
going on because of the pandemic and
it's rapping like regardless of who you
vote for it's going to rap education to
be happening for quality education to be
happening and i don't think that
critical race theory has any any place
in our public schools
man people are just so confused about
everything it's it's really crazy
um
here's our friend farron cousins he may
be filling in for me a little bit in
december more information about that
upcoming
that may be it as far as these in a lot
of the same ones keep coming up we
looked at that one we looked at this one
um
okay all right good well so we took a
look at that
and uh
we're continuing to watch all of these
different
oh my god it's rick santorum on newsmax
this i have to see popular yeah you know
terry mcauliffe the white house will
blame terry mcauliffe he made mistakes
but the president unpopularity turned a
deep blue state into a narrow red state
and in addition to that i mean we're
following the house of delegates race
so far that i've reported we've that
republicans have picked up four of the
six they need uh to well they need seven
to take the majority so and there's
still a lot of races that are very much
in place so
again to the point that mark was making
this isn't just about terry mcauliffe
being a bad candidate this is about a a
a bigger wave than that that you're
seeing down ballot races you know we one
other thing i want to talk about is
loudoun county you know we looked at
loudoun and you're saying gosh you only
got 55 mcauliffe got 55 percent but if
you look at the the election day vote
actually it was i think yunkan wanted by
one so
the early vote is a lot of change in the
last two weeks as you know there's an
emergency radio offer that they're doing
there here's the yunkan party let's
listen in not be doing as well as he
should in a state that's controlled by
the democratic party so it sounds like
they're just listening to tucker at the
yunkan party isn't really relevant to
his job
the bill of rights as you well know
protects americans right and shrines
their right to practice their religion
as they see fit and to congregate
together to assemble peacefully
by what authority did you nullify the
bill of rights in issuing this order
okay
all right thank you if you're just
joining us terry mcauliffe has lost
virginia democrats have lost virginia
this is really bad for democrats this
doesn't bode well for 2022. this doesn't
bode well
it just doesn't bode well for democrats
i don't know how else to say it it's a
very bad thing it signals this race was
plus nine ralph northam in 2017
right now it's plus 10 the republican
glenn youncan
virginia's not a deep blue state but
it's it's been we believed going more
consistently blue
and it's it's gone the other direction
let's see if dave wasserman has any
other info for us here
uh calling the lieutenant governor's
race for the republican as well folks we
are moments from starting to get data
from i believe new york and boston
mayoral to important races
um
eric adams the democratic candidate in
new york city
and a friend of the show michelle wu
one of the candidates
in boston
um
very very exciting stuff just as a
reminder let's go brandon is a bannable
phrase it's just annoying and stupid
okay
so i just banned another person for
using it
and we will we will continue banning
those folks it's just you're gonna
you're gonna keep getting banned it's
not it's not gonna stop
and um
you know you you do with that what you
want if you feel good about it then
great
but it's just it's just too much i to
say thanks to willa vanilla and
boceratops for the twitch prime
subscriptions also thank you to miles
berkins using the coupon code felony21
to sign up on my website folks we are
four members away
from hitting the completely arbitrary
and meaningless goal of 100
which
you can't even imagine how meaningful
that is it's it's really
it's really something else
um standing by for results there
um
oh georgia people want to see
oh atlanta mayor as well okay yeah so in
atlanta
felicia moore is leading right now based
on 500 votes
extremely early extremely early we don't
yet have any information from buffalo
um it's all it's all zeros i believe at
nine in five minutes
we're going to get some information
there and we're monitoring all of these
different channels
and meet the press coverage starts in
four minutes as well so i want to keep
an eye on that that's very very
important
a lot of these different things are
going to be coming up
and they're going to be major major
races to follow shane says via super
chat david thanks for presenting the
news in a calm objective manner very
refreshing
thank you
i thought the dems would change their
game after trump after what the
republicans did with the supreme court
and the insurrection what do we do next
history repeats itself with the dems but
the republicans changing the game
bay photo sees need more proof
the crap tucker does works
yeah
very very uh true
do you think cop 26 will yield results i
think cop 26 you you guys want to hear i
mean if this is going to be depressing
for people because this is not
optimistic
i believe that the cop 26 talks
will lead to
vague
probably achievable
but completely unenforceable
commitments
on climate
call me crazy
call me crazy
katya says thank you for all the live
streams they make difficult situations
significantly more digestible some rough
stuff this week we appre appreciate you
thank you yeah i'm going to be back
tomorrow with uh kyle at the kyle
rittenhouse trial
look at this what is this you guys see
that
what is that
oh my god we got to get that out of the
way that's not very unprofessional
sorry about it i i'm sorry about
that i i apologize
um tomorrow we're gonna continue with
kyle rittenhouse and it's it's been
pretty brutal pretty brutal
um i wanna say a big thank you to adam
ruther who is a new member on my website
justina tyson
as well as william moss
new members 97
98 and 99 folks member number 100 gets a
free item from my online store any item
you want we'll ship it anywhere in the
world that we can i think the only
places we can't ship are
some places in the middle east north
korea
um
antarctica maybe
we could we could basically ship
anywhere else the the whoever is number
100
you will if you want a free item from my
online store
rupert murdoch has shown that he hates
america as he runs it from abroad at
least is indifferent
right
he's indifferent to living in america we
can put it that way
uh he doesn't care the effect that fox
news has on america because he doesn't
even live here that could be fair
although some of his kids do
um
yeah i think there's a number of
different ways we could
oh hold on i gotta ban more people
guys remember let's go brandon gets you
banned it's just trolling
it's just trolling
uh people
saying don't support anything that i do
so that's a ban
i mean guys if you're just troll if
there's bad faith trolling you're just
getting banned i don't care
people being clever with let's go
brandon that's a ban twitch is so well
behaved tonight guys youtube can you
just behave a little more like the
twitch audience
the twitch audies
they're substantively participating in
chat there's very little trolling
it's
at least tonight
it's just come on guys you should see
what's happening on youtube it's it's
should be illegal it really should no
i'm kidding it shouldn't be illegal uh
it's not it's not a legal issue
okay top of the hour
and we are moments from our first data
from new york city
buffalo
atlanta and boston mayoral a lot coming
up here momentarily
yunkan people are going wild
all right i guess they cut the audio
um
geez
something must have gone very wrong
there how can dems message more
effectively to combat republican
simplistic black white framing of issues
we have objectively better policy
positions check out my interview with
george lakoff on that
we've spoken about that quite a bit
um
check out my interview maybe with thomas
frank we've we've talked about that a
little bit with him as well
uh
just a couple other people i gotta ban
there's just a lot of banning going it's
sad that so many people are get we
probably have thousands of people that
have been banned it's really crazy
um let's see here
thanks for not commenting on my last
super chat
yeah you know we've got a lot going on
oh here we go
i will make an effort to read but not
necessarily comment on every message
tonight the first clues to the 2022
midterms and which party will control
congress the first major test for both
parties since the presidential election
two big governor's races in virginia a
dead heat between democrat terry
mcauliffe i am a uniter glenn young
we're getting massachusetts
do you want government control in your
life or do you want freedom nothing
jersey it's democratic governor phil
murphy it is sunrise in new jersey
versus republican jack citarelli you
thought the last four years are bad wait
until this guy is unencumbered plus big
mayoral races from new york city look at
me
and you're seeing the future of the
democratic party to boston i am running
to tackle the big changes
boston in partnership with community to
minneapolis detroit cleveland buffalo
atlanta and miami also key ballot
measures on everything from peyote to
police
housing to health complete coverage of
decision 2021 begins right now
on nbc news now
wow
this is a meet the press election night
special
live from washington here are chuck todd
and kristen welcome
well that music can mean only one thing
it is election night in america results
are coming in we are in for a jam-packed
night could be a long night early
morning that's right it's already very
busy chuck that's for sure and tonight a
lot more is at stake than some big
governor's races we're also watching
special congressional elections mayoral
contests and ballot initiatives look
it's effectively opening day of the 2022
midterms with an incredible first game
so this one is not too close to call
it's been called already young one
multiple multiple calls over the
governor things are not breaking the
democrats way at least so far polls
closed by two hours ago and our nbc news
election deaths has categorized this
race too close to call however we can
characterize it this way that republican
glenn younkin is in the lead
so too close to incredible analysis it's
about a one to three point spread in
younkin's favor but there's still more
numbers to come in democrats everywhere
are anxiously watching these returns
because this is a state that joe biden
won by 10 points last year and ralph
northam the outgoing governor won by
nine in 2017.
this race has historically been an
excellent indicator for both parties
ahead of the following years midterms if
democrats lose this race all right so
they're not giving anything giving us
anything you in fact they're very very
far behind i want to congratulate paige
lang who just signed up on my website
using the coupon code felony 21 and his
new member number 100
you get a free item from my online store
if you so please email info
davidpakman.com
um and uh give us the information what
you want color size address we will get
it to you a whole bunch of other people
signing up thanks to darius barksdale
scott labrie
danielle villella
robert esslinger brenna tyson brenna
welcome
paolo raimondi is a new member on my
website
that's six okay 100 plus six
zero plus six is six nothing to carry
zero plus zero one blue that puts us at
one hundred and six
for the evening
also a big thank you to shane perro
allen minsart julianne hart zach
callahan
and john white clay white clay i like
that last name i've not heard that
before
really appreciate that also thank you to
everyone supporting us on twitch tonight
that includes
kumadatsu toil shane pert the clay
margot cabot potpot ux sebster's lab
rocio duran
and badness putting us at 119. it's an
historic evening an election night with
so much going on let's now go to the
data and see if we are starting to get
information about these mayoral races
key mayoral races in new york city we
have nothing we have absolutely no
information in new york city does anyone
know
are we
expecting information from new york
tonight is it is it one of these things
where we're just not going to have
anything tonight
from massachusetts
we have nothing yet from boston mayoral
although we do have numbers coming in
from um state house primaries state
house primaries
so we're going to keep watching that as
well but these are some major major
races
taking place here
as numbers continue to come in
it has been called for glenn younkin it
has been called for glen yunken although
not every network wants to do it
maybe to push ratings i don't know
i don't know
thanks to racio duran for the website
membership now double dipping new member
number 120 using the coupon code
felony21 an explosive evening why don't
we just go for 150 i mean why not right
super chats continue to come in dems are
appeasing republicans like chamberlain
did hitler that's a bit much it's a bit
much
yeet onometry
says never mind the nonsense we love
pacman thank you
mark fillion says just like george
carlin said the planet is fine
the people are lost
jimmy from philly says i have a special
bowl
to catch liberal tears
yikes
sinsu
says so concerned that before long shows
like yours will necessarily go
underground yes
for security reasons as many of you were
told earlier
i am in the bunker
i am in the bunker this is a green
screen
um
we have been moved into the bunker
uh
for reasons i shouldn't even really be
talking about but often on elections it
happens
but i want to make everybody feel
comfortable so we filmed the studio and
now have it as a green screen background
i have to tell you guys
it looks pretty freaking good
uh i did an inspection of the bunker
earlier today
and it really looks good
so that's happening
we should just demand a recount and an
audit this election was obviously
fraudulent we should storm virginia
state capital that's what we do now
yeah
um
i i understand the point i understand
the point
clearly yunkan has made huge inroads
back into the suburbs at least gotten
whatever whatever the anti-trump
republican or anti-trump independent
vote that seems to have come home to a
point that and of itself may tell this
story but mark murray you've talked
about the death by a thousand cuts for
terry mcauliffe and it's in all of these
red areas let's just take you to a
little bristol virginia here washington
county big yunkan county here but look
at these raw vote totals yes he's over
performing okay
so i think you guys get the gist of
what's being presented there um abc has
still not called it for glenn younkin
cbs news i don't believe has called it
for glenn juncken
and nbc news they're doing an entire dog
and pony show as if it hasn't been
called but it has been called at this
point by decision desk hq they're very
good
it's also been called by dave wasserman
who continues to tweet
um just about the only places where
seeing mcauliffe exceed vote targets are
inside the beltway not enough to win
but it is enough to keep yunkan's
eventual margin quite narrow maybe two
or three percent
uh i that that's i think the most
accurate thing
that has been said
um
thank you to melissa johns for signing
up on my website as well as sarah oakley
sarah used the coupon code felony 21 new
members 121 and 122.
um
[Music]
we are getting oh i'm told we have some
numbers now from new york is that true
we do not no
let's see when are new york mayoral
results
expected
new york city election results
i mean eric adams is going to win i
don't even know
oh hold on politico has the data
look at this folks
politico has new york city mayoral
elements
and uh it's it's it's over yeah eric
adams will be the next mayor of new york
um
curtis sliwa
with 9 reporting down almost four to one
almost four to one so
data coming in
from politico for whatever reason
decision desk hq does not have it but
politico does and it is going to be
eric adams not a surprise not a surprise
let's see
if they have
uh let's see boston mayoral
results
expected maybe maybe these numbers are
out
live results boston mayoral
wbur oh we've got data
decision desk hq falling woefully behind
our friend michelle wu is out to an
early start
over anissa sieb george
16 reporting whoa
um
and michelle wu
in the david pakman show universe
very nice
we like her
out to a 58 to 41 lead 58 to 41 lead for
michelle wu
and eric adams it is over folks it has
been called democrat eric adams politico
has called it in new york city mayoral
it will be eric adams it will not be
curtis sliwa that's a very good thing
we didn't want curtis sliwa
decision desk hq
just lacking here
they just don't have uh they don't have
the information it's very strange
showing all zeros maybe not the best
dashboard i don't know
we'll continue to monitor virginia here
it is over in new york it is over in new
york staten island um the one red part
of new york city went sliva so far 5440
but still 91 percent of the vote to be
counted there everything else very very
blue
new york county which is manhattan 85 to
10
bronx 81 to 16. queens 68 to 27 queens
does have some more conservative areas
particularly i think out up here near
long island
and then kings county which contains
brooklyn brooklyn folks 80 to 15
very aggressively happening very very
aggressively happening
over in massachusetts
with
still 16 percent
oh wait a second can we actually get
this seems to be an associated press
elections is it here
where do we have the results
live updates
sure we're to get the results from ap
in any case this these these data
the multiple datum
um
michelle wu is ahead by 17 points right
now 17 points so some interesting
numbers starting to develop here i want
to say thank you to we slow wieslow819
for the twitch subscription you are
number 123 today very much appreciate it
over on my website crystal wade just
signed up with the coupon code felony21
if you're just joining us we have
endless streams this week we streamed
yesterday we had day one of the kyle
rittenhouse trial today we had day two
we're doing election results tomorrow we
will be back at it with day three of
kyle rittenhouse i would love it if you
grabbed a membership on my website to
support the work we do you can use the
coupon code above my head in bold to get
a big discount also thanks to michelle
graham
for the twitch prime subscription
appreciate that
um
we've got a lot
a lot of people
that are getting banned particularly on
youtube it's just horrifying what's
going on horrifying and what's
interesting also is we have we have
established a new
um element i guess we would call it over
on youtube where you need to be
subscribed to my channel to chat because
we thought that that would sort of
reduce the trolling imagine if right now
anybody could just troll on through it
would be absolutely horrifying
absolutely absolutely horrifying newsmax
now projecting a young can win in
virginia expecting that of course here's
the scene at glenn younkin's party
um nbc news coverage
updating a variety of different races
cbs now saying that it's leaning
republican in virginia it's over as it's
been called by multiple multiple folks
let's take a listen to that legacy of
that rural turnout that donald trump
created and glenn young was able to
capitalize on but also to kind of chip
away into the northern virginia suburbs
into some of the swing counties like
chesterfield in some ways he was able to
pull it off but as we've talked about
not every republican nominee is going to
be able to have a convention and also
400 million dollars of personal wealth
to be able to pull off that feat hey
joshua johnson i'm already violating a
rule that i swore
i know what it's like not to be the lone
guy not on set
and you're like what are you doing i
have been in your position and i'm like
come on brian
15 minutes through the first hour and
look how you do me already let's see how
this goes
uh mr johnson uh you heard me conflate
my florida uh a little bit of my florida
roots you've got florida roots and there
is something very eeriely similar here
where
terry mcauliffe looks like this looks
like 2016 to me a little bit right terry
mccullough's doing what he has to do
and there's this rural
tide uh coupled with what does chuck
todd what what analysis is this what
we're staring at what do you see
yeah i mean i i see what you're saying
in terms of the florida connection i'm a
little bit of a contrarian on this one
this may get me uninvited from future
election nights but i'll take this
i am actually not contrarian i'm a
little bit mixed in terms of what i
think about virginia being a national
bellwether i think virginia
for anyone who's lived there or near
there kind of gets that it's a very
different sort of state for many other
states
extremely well educated
very high net worth like the idea that
loudoun county is such a high net worth
place but this is west of washington dc
and the debate over education is not
about like standardized test scores or
kids on free and reduced lunches but
it's about the way we talk about race
says a lot but the other thing that i
think is going to be a significant
bellwether tonight is what happens with
the races from mayor
because i think a lot of what's going on
in the country right now is not about
co is it not about
education it's about covet it's about
the economy and it's about crime in our
nbc news exit poll we asked which
candidate do you trust to deal with
kovid better younkin or mcauliffe most
people said mcauliffe crime
most people said young kim and a lot of
the races tonight just that's a partisan
bias that's not unique to this race in
seattle they're dealing with issues of
criminal justice minneapolis is voting
tonight on whether to disband the police
department like these are the kinds of
practical executive issues that might
end up being more of a bellwether with
the rest of the country especially as
you mentioned guys i don't know that i
agree
if virginia goes from plus nine democrat
to plus 10 republican now i understand
at the end of the day it might only be
plus three republican
um
that's a major factor for 2022
it's a major major factor it's good for
republicans i don't know that i agree
with this analysis reality maybe if we
view
all of it we'll have a better sense of
where america is going actually you're
not being constrained i totally agree
with you in fact i'm curious if you
accept this premise let's all agree that
actually if you look at the entire
election landscape for tonight and you
brought up those mayor's races plus new
jersey and virginia essentially this is
a referendum on democratic philosophy
and governance and a debate really more
inside the democratic party about how
should we govern how should cities be
governed um
in some ways
it seems like all of these races are a
little bit right let's get back to some
of our numbers in the new york city
mayoral it's over if you're just joining
us as expected eric adams has won over
republican curtis sliwa that is the guy
with the red beret from the thing the
subway people
and um in the city of boston
with still just 16 reporting michelle wu
um
is leading by 17 leading by 17 there
so that's the latest
there
they're still counting votes in virginia
it has tightened a little bit to about
nine points with 72 percent in guardian
angels yeah um
but it is
clearly not going to be enough and it's
been called it's already been called
this is the glenn younkin party here
and uh you can see just
lovely lovely people there
news matt let's listen to the news max
analysis
property taxes in the nation the gas tax
has had gas tax has been hiked twice
in the last year
and the income taxes literally
confiscatory so when
when the governor says well if you're
worried about taxes this isn't the state
for you how many people can afford not
to worry about taxes the current
governor is a goldman sachs millionaire
but most people work for a living and
they get their paycheck and they're
worried about how they're going to pay
their taxes especially their property
taxes
yeah that's a very good point i'm
looking right now ocean county was heavy
trump
in the last election monmouth was not
that heavy uh for trump it was it was
lightly won by trump citarelli maybe
making some gains in monmouth county and
doing a little bit better there so
they seem to sort of be holding it
together over there to some degree i
want to say thank you to your billion
steve the doc
and cold pressed juice box i appreciate
you signing up via twitch prime also a
huge shout out huge shout out and thank
you to ryan hughes who just got a
membership on my website and trevor
evans young who just got a membership on
my website using the coupon code
felony21
it saves you
a disgusting amount of money
disgust just come if you know
you decide but it saves a disgusting
amount of money let's get to some super
chats joe bullon says i think if this
will come down to turnout
what will the virginia thing is over
or do you mean 2022 how do we motivate
the blue for 2022 well just imagine all
the things we have to talk very
specifically about what happens if
republicans take control in november
lisa murkowski says she will vote yes to
break a filibuster on the john lewis
voting rights replacement advancement
act she's the only republican i'll look
at that for tomorrow
i'm pretty sure if chuck todd agrees
with you you're a contrarian
hey dave david lisa mikowski said she
would end the filibuster on john ly's
act
uh okay
audit the virginia ballots to screen for
chesapeake blue crab fibers yes
absolutely
we need to do that
very very suspicious stuff on those uh
on those ballots could could really be
anything on there
could really be anything on there
um
so let's see what are we waiting on
right now um over in georgia we had the
mayoral in atlanta
very little reporting there although
maybe there's a better now i'm doubting
this
atlanta mayor election results
let's see what we've got
atlanta mayor's race
no there's really almost no reporting
out of atlanta yet okay
so that's not inaccurate
not inaccurate
uh
michigan
detroit mayor incumbent mike duggan
doing very well there now with 55
reporting probably 10 minutes from being
called
so that's going to be
over
minnesota
um
no data yet
st paul no data there either
jersey's looking very good for phil
murphy although whoa all of a sudden
it's just gotten way closer look at that
oh my goodness this could get very could
this be a massacre for democrats
phil murphy all of a sudden down to just
a six point lead all of a sudden
that's not so good
so we're gonna have to look at that
yeah there were some some vote dumps big
massive dumps
that's uh that's not so good so we're
watching new jersey
over in ohio
um
chantal brown has won yeah i mean not
even close
cincinnati mayor we're getting some data
in aftab porval i don't know any of
these candidates
i don't know for example in toledo i've
not heard of cardi finkbeiner and i've
not heard of wabe wade
kapsukovitz
yeah
but we're watching all of those races
pennsylvania
state house pittsburgh mayor
very little reporting but the democrat
is ahead as well
there's um
oh let's see do we have any data from
buffalo
buffalo new york mayor
results
let's see what we've got
i'm not seeing anything
uh oh no wait a second
i'm seeing india walton getting crushed
check this out
this is like super early
but there are some results here
look at this website is horrifying
with zero precincts oh no hold on a
second there was just something else i
just saw other numbers
it's weird
i looked at this in a different browser
and it said india walton was down
that's bizarre in firefox it shows
results
and in chrome it doesn't let's refresh
here
brown's campaign is writing meaning
votes will not be counted until november
15. so i don't think we're gonna have
anything here yeah it's very strange
this shows nothing i'm looking at this
very same window in firefox and it says
write in 65 india walton 35
at the same time we're told
we're not going to have any day oh here
it is
see it just popped up
this is what i was looking at in another
browser
6535 right in defeating india walton
i just i just think it's it's not really
clear what's going on
i think we're going to need to wait on
this it's not really clear what's going
on
um
yeah
and now it's just it's the website's
really funky very very funky website
let's listen european trip they also
think that there's an element here of
frankly because things aren't getting
done uh sharing mcauliffe represents the
same old same old and people are again
looking for something new so the mood
glum inside the camp but they still say
too close to call they believe that
there are paths however small chuck well
i'm impressed chris uh that your source
was being honest uh because it's
certainly the impression they've given
us well i assume glum is not the word
garrett hank that you're going to use to
describe the scene at yonkin
headquarters tell us uh
and there's already different
conservative groups that have put out
victory statements are they acting as if
this is over or do they
okay
that was a quick answer
take it away brother
okay
chuck the only people glum at this event
right now are those in the back of the
line for the bar the yunkan uh
celebration event has been in full-on
victory party mode for about the last
hour they're absolutely convinced that
they've got this sewn up that they hit
the marks that they were trying to hit
in places like loudoun county in the red
counties that are go down the spine of
western virginia they hit the you know
the trump style numbers that they needed
to hit and they've seen no indication
that there's going to be any kind of
last second turnaround
from the late numbers in northern
virginia fairfax county arlington
alexandria and so forth they think
they've got this shown up and they were
feeling confident over the last couple
of days not just because of this late
surge uh particularly focused on the
education issue that chris alluded to
but really going back to what they saw
as a collapse in joe biden's numbers
here in virginia starting around the
time of the pull out from afghanistan as
the biden numbers start to get soft they
saw their numbers improve they found
this to be a winnable race and then they
felt like and i heard this from sources
in and around the younkin campaign in
the last couple of days that terry
mcauliffe ran fundamentally the wrong
campaign here that he ran maybe a senate
campaign easy to say 2020 or 2018
campaign and the trying to make glenn
younkin into a scary you know 6'5 donald
trump in a sweater vest in khakis who
shoots hoops just wasn't going to work
here virginia voters were kind of past
it and that they didn't find jungkook to
be a scary figure effectively giving a
hall pass to independents to moderate
republicans perhaps who had turned
against the party during the trump years
to come back on board and that seems to
be what we're seeing here tonight but as
you can probably hear around me uh at
this party here in fairfax county uh
republicans feel like this is a victory
party tonight
i bet look uh we have a call that we're
about to make uh in in new york city but
i want to wrap up a quick eric adams one
uh mark murray glenn younkin
actually looks if you put him in the
lineup of republican governors
he actually looks g any sort of demeanor
everything uh bob mcdonnell george
allen's governor's race jim gilmore's
governor's race right all of those
republican governors andrew mark they
ran very
um
don't call me a republican race and in
each one of them and they both ran i
don't know why i'm finding chuck todd a
little bit annoying um we called the
yeah the eric adams new york city race
was called a little while ago we are
still standing by for results from new
york city mayoral at the last refresh it
was 16
it is still 16 as far as we can tell i
don't believe there is newer data
uh from nyc from um decision desk yes
nothing new yet
i want to say a huge thank you
to montyan for gifting 10 twitch
subscriptions putting us solidly at 140
also jeremy marchand
and joseph tobias have signed up on my
website getting us to 142. we have a
stretch goal here of 150 and we're very
very close i really appreciate everybody
who's been signing up on my website the
coupon code will be good all night
that's felony 21.
um so
uh
new york city mayoral it's eric adams
guess we'll listen to the call here
uh he uh we expected him to win this
fairly comfortably
and you know andrea mitchell eric adams
i'm still sort of having that flashback
when he said i am the face of the
democrat of this of this of the current
version of the democratic party it would
be fascinating to watch him yeah just a
quick note about curtis lewis whom we've
seen in new york politics and you know
activism for decades but the fact that
he had all of those cats in that one
group apartment
i still can't get over that
i still remember him in the guardian
angel days i didn't like think that guys
is he the son of that guy or is that
still there
and i think eric adams
i think he's interesting he's the second
african-american mayor to be elected in
new york and he really had a law and
order message at a time when we are
debating uh this discussion defund the
police
and of course there are various versions
of that but he comes from that as he
says joshua johnson
joshua johnson eric adams yeah the role
he's going to play what do you expect i
think he is interested in being part of
the national conversation i don't think
he's interested in being uh mr city hall
no he may not be super interested in
being mr city hall although he's been
talking speaking to a lot of issues here
in new york that
new yorkers are very
concerned with um i think one of the big
ones like we mentioned earlier is going
to be law enforcement there was this
big f there's been this big ongoing
fight in terms of vaccine mandates and
what's going to happen with fire
department of new york and nypd if they
don't get back i don't know if you guys
heard
there's 6 36 000 nypd officers
the union was saying
um
10 000
might quit over the vaccine mandate 34
actually did david have you seen the
tucker clip of him covering how joe
biden is turning orange like trump no
that i'm going to try to find that right
now like the one i'm sitting in right
now where people evacuated for covet and
haven't all come back what do you do in
new york where there are storefronts
that have closed on mass people are
slowly coming back and we're trying to
figure out how to make this a city that
you can come visit and have things to do
when you finish coming to see fallon or
whatever you choose to do here in new
york what do you do with a city where
you're hearing more dirt bikes racing up
and down sixth house and more homeless
people on the streets and it just seems
like i found this it seems two months
old is the only thing let's take a look
back in january liberals around the
world celebrated the white house was no
longer occupied by an orange president
now a lot of
viewers of this show have noticed
something
joe biden is turning orange it's not an
exaggeration look at the pictures in
other words i mean the funny thing is in
this video tucker looks the exact same
shade of orange as joe biden the orange
man is back
what's happening here
is there something about the white house
that turns people orange is this a joke
is it the water is it something else we
don't know but we're going to stay on
that store oh hold on the water i have i
have a clip about that
surrounded by
water big water ocean one of the wettest
we've ever seen from the standpoint of
water
all right well that's strange it's a
very strange clip i don't know
the oranges of it
but a very very unusual clip for sure
don't really know what to
what to make of it um i guess the result
i'm watching most closely now is new
york city mayoral where we still have
just 16 reporting let me see if i can
find something with more updated
information boston mayoral
results 2021 see if we've got anything
newer
um
no new york times it seems 16 is this
just the most we've got right now
boston.com
yeah no that's that's the latest we've
got thanks to jr dubs for the twitch
prime sub very much appreciate it uh
let's go to a few super chats here david
i'm doing my senior seminar paper over
white evangelicals versus modern human
secularism i want to know if it's okay
if i could quote you
i can't
anything that's public you can quote you
don't need my permission if it's public
it can be quoted it would be weird for
me like no don't quote a public video on
youtube
jack says new jersey governor is now
down to about a point difference oh [ __ ]
this is becoming the race of the night
oh my goodness
incumbent new jersey governor phil
murphy who jumped out to a just
massive massive lead
um is now down to only a two point
uh eight eight percent lead
big massive dumps yeah
jack chatterelli
seems to have received
huge ballot dumps
that is crazy
phil murphy could end up
the democratic incumbent in jersey could
end up losing now jersey does weird
stuff
jersey does weird stuff but that we've
got to watch that really really closely
um
okay a lot of kind of strange super
chats here not all ones that i can
really respond to
in any substantive way
but
appreciate it nonetheless we're gonna
have to watch that really really closely
that's not looking good so basically
we've got boston mayoral now
and jersey gubernatorial is all of a
sudden looking absolutely horrible
absolutely horrible
uh let's take a few calls i promised to
take calls if we would get to 100
website members
uh whoa hold on let's open up
discord over here uh we do take calls
via
discord uh that's davidpakman.com
we'll take some calls while we wait for
some more results to come in
okay
um let me see what else is going on here
um
yeah let's talk to some people if you
want to talk to me
go into the waiting lobby
in the uh
discord
and momentarily
we are going to be able to chat let's
make sure my audio video settings are
appropriate
uh correct microphone yep that's all
going yeah i want to chat with a few
people now we're watching results come
in and we're going gonna have more
results momentarily
um
so let's listen to
what a few people have to say at least
let's listen to oh is this adam from
virginia adam you calling from virginia
i am fairfax county yeah it's pretty bad
isn't it
it i started drinking the moment you
called it oh really what are you
drinking
uh i've got three i poured three fingers
of whiskey oof okay what whiskey
uh jack uh just uh gentleman jack
gentleman jack all right well so i mean
it's this this what is i i
was completely unsure as to who would be
likely to win but were there like rumors
today that it wasn't looking good for
terry
yeah i
felt it wasn't looking good um
i i there wasn't really any indicator
when i went to the poll or uh my polling
place it was basically deserted i was
meeting three other people there oh boy
and now was is that a bad sign probably
right
yeah that's what i felt but you know
but yeah no i just really disappointed
in the race today but
you know
outside of the beltway it turns well the
beltway in richmond it turns very red
very fast so
it's horrifying it's horrifying yeah so
i guess now what i mean i guess you know
we see what happens with the members of
congress in 2022.
yeah i'm worried about that too now yeah
um yeah
i mean the the whole bad press from
biden and congress not being able to get
this infrastructure bill passed and
it's just
much like taran mccall if it's death by
a thousand cuts no doubt
no doubt adam i'm echoing so i'm gonna
let you go but i appreciate the call and
we want best of luck of course
continuing in virginia we want to turn
things around let's go now to another
state that's hotly contested where the
democratic incumbent governor maybe just
i mean it's now down to 0.99
it is under a point let's go to surya
from new jersey surya what the hell is
going on over there
i know uh i'm my pessimism is increasing
let's put it that way sorry your what is
increasing
my pessimism your pessimism yeah um it's
i mean were you was anyone expecting it
to be this close in jersey
no i mean i'm actually from one of the
few republican areas in new jersey um
but uh we
the um reliably uh you know the race
goes to democrats here especially in
like the middle and southern counties
what county
i'd like to see the results can you
describe what county you are like on a
drawing of new jersey
yes i'm from bergen county which is all
the way at the top on the right side oh
okay okay okay yeah we have no results
from there yet at least on decision desk
hq
oh npr says sixty percent for citarelli
right now oh okay okay yeah so for
whatever reason these these results on
decision desk don't seem to be that
updated but all right so it's not
looking great there
yeah i'm really i'm really sad yeah
all right well we're going to keep
watching it the oh my god chattarelli's
now in the lead
folks
chatrelli's now leading by point 19 it's
about two
not even it's like 1400 votes or
something like that so it's not looking
good surya
yeah this is actually my first year
casting a vote because i just turned 18
so oh okay
well listen i'm glad you're engaged i'm
glad you're engaged
yeah thank you thank you let's hope for
the best yes for sure all right there
you go good luck in new jersey guys this
is looking
very bad if you're just joining us
um virginia has been called
for glenn youngan
there were just all these votes that
came in
big massive dumps and it's been called
we now are looking at new jersey jersey
looked safe
looked very safe
and phil murphy was winning like two to
one then he was winning by like 20.
um it is now down to
a situation where the incumbent
democratic if an incumbent democratic
governor in the democratic state of new
jersey loses it's very very bad
very very bad for democrats
let's check in with a couple of other
people here
why don't we go to
uh
let's see if we've got anybody else
in a relevant location
um
let's go to marshall from
is it down state or downstairs where's
where are you calling from marshall
i'm calling from down state illinois oh
down state of illinois i suppose to
chicago yeah what's going on there
um i wanted to ask you
there there seems to be some a narrative
especially on the left that
people want people vote based on issues
and substance
but i i that just seems so
misguided to me from where i stand it
seems like people
vote almost entirely on cultural issues
the culture wars and stuff like that
what do you what is your take on that
i disagree with that so let me give you
an analogy
and i just poured water all over myself
uh marshall so i'm just gonna mop up a
little bit here just to make sure we
don't get disconnected due to a short
circuit
um
if you paid attention to the democratic
primary on reddit and twitter
you would have gotten the impression
that the democratic electorate was way
more to the left than it really was you
would have gotten the impression that
bernie sanders was way more popular than
he really was and then we had the actual
democratic primary and it turned out joe
biden easily won
along the same lines i think that
cultural issues are significantly played
up
by the media
and
on websites like reddit and twitter
when in reality i really do think um
particu i'm talking about democrats here
i really do think democrats are
not primarily voting along cultural
issues i think in recent time because
republicans have completely abandoned
even pretending to be about policy
i think there's a lot of republicans
voting along cultural issues but
uh that that's my sense right now
so it's mainly mainly a partisan split i
do think so i do think so
thanks david my pleasure uh there's
marshall from downstate illinois folks
if you're just joining us
it has gotten very ugly
incumbent
democratic new jersey governor
in a blue state
is losing
is losing jack chatterelli
could defeat
blue governor
in blue state and it would be a disaster
for democrats let's see if anybody's
picking up on this
uh nbc talking about virginia
cbs talking about minnesota
and abc talking about virginia
but look at these numbers
phil murphy's losing the incumbent is
losing right now
let's get updated numbers from boston
nothing updated okay so we're gonna keep
uh we're gonna keep watching those
let's take a caller eric from virginia
eric you're on the air
hello oh my goodness uh yes please step
away from the phone just a little bit
hello can you hear me yeah i like that
quiet voice please
uh so i have a question for you
um
so it was
quite a
quarter race in my
state
uh do you think uh
oh god why are you working on who won
that shouldn't even be a question on who
won uh virginia who was it
it was it mcauliffe who won virginia
are are you asking me the results is
that what you're asking
yeah i'm just blanking on the name
because i've been there i've just been
watching so much results
it's been called for glenn younkin on
many channels
do you do you think
uh
mcauliffe even had a chance at women yes
i think he had a chance but he lost
okay
uh great thank you david pleasure thank
you eric you can also if anybody needs
to know the results just look them up
but you don't be i mean waiting on hold
seems annoying you can just google the
results let's go next sticking in
virginia to elysian in northern virginia
elite is it pronounced elysian
i actually say it elijah but all my
friends just call me elliott okay now
elijah you've gotta silence discord
because it's already blinging and
blanging and it's it's
i'm gonna have to dump uh because
otherwise we're gonna lose all of our
viewers
okay oh boy
that's two strikes i'm just warning you
keep going come back to me i'll figure
that out
and there's number three strike three uh
okay
let's go to
um
ben from boston ben are you watching the
boston results and how are you feeling
about them so far
can you hear me now yes i can okay cool
yeah i've been watching i voted for wu
a little bit earlier today around noon
all right um
she's looks like she's doing pretty good
so far but not too many updates yep 16
in she's winning by 17 right now
yeah it seems like that's been it's been
stuck there for a while yeah
unfortunately um
yeah i was just uh wondering kind of um
what your uh thoughts about her and
um kind of potential you know
progressive in boston what you know the
things that she could uh what really
impressed uh you with her um in terms of
you know
boston politics yeah i mean i i've i've
not followed the race super closely and
i uh i i'm not currently voting in
boston but i know michelle a little bit
i know she's aware of the david pakman
show i think she's great i think she's
very smart i like her energy i like her
general predisposition and approach to
this to the city of boston so i would
have voted for her if i was a boston
voter um i think uh i i hope she wins
and i think she'll be a great mayor
you think you'll be able to get her on
the show oh god i hope so i mean that
would it would be criminal if i wasn't
able to after all this
yeah that would be great uh just one
thing i was just wondering if you saw
this uh tweet by uh it's now been
deleted uh by emerald uh robinson who is
the white house correspondent from
newsmax maxwell
did you see this tweet about um her
talking about uh luciferase in the the
coveted vaccine no it's completely bogus
and uh yeah luciferase
yeah i'm actually a scientist and i use
uh
luciferase is a commonly used enzyme
from
fireflies
let me let me explain to the audience
what's going on newsmax star
claims vaccines contained
bioluminescent tracker linked to the
devil
twitter eventually took down the tweet i
want to see the exact quote
dear christians the vaccines contain a
bioluminescent marker called luciferase
so i guess the right pronunciation would
be luciferase so that you can be tracked
read the latest book of the new
testament to see how this ends you know
how can we not say that that's mental
illness like when you claim it to be
from scripture supposedly we have to
pretend you're healthy but it that
that's that's weaponized that that's
horrifying
yeah it's uh it's pretty ridiculous um
yeah it's pretty pretty debunked even if
it was in the vaccine who cares it's
just a name of a protein it
comes from a latin root you know hey you
know what um i i read actually that the
vaccines contain hitler race
yeah yeah
okay thanks thanks for the call i
appreciate no thank you you called me
and i really do appreciate it and we're
going to keep going with michelle wu
um let's see who else we want to talk to
oh let's update on this race here oh my
goodness guys
phil murphy may be about to be removed
from office
phil murphy the incumbent
democratic governor of blue state new
jersey is now losing by 2.2 percentage
points this was supposed to be hold on
who am i talking to i just heard is
someone still on with me
did you guys hear that
no
okay somehow it's white night i'm gonna
have to server mute white knight that
was weird
how did white knight get on with me that
was strange
very very weird
uh okay
um
guys please don't do that okay that's
not that's not funny um jack chattarali
now leading by uh 2.2
okay let's go next to roy from south
jersey roy what the hell is going on in
jersey
you know we still haven't gotten the
suburbs of new york or uh much of philly
so i wouldn't be too worried right now
hold on a second you guys are counting
philadelphia in the jersey
that sounds illegal
yeah
yeah um my question was do you think
that um you know power coalescing around
trump is a good thing because you know
he's
he's he's up there he's going to die and
then you know there's going to be a
power vacuum in the republican party
yeah
you're saying is it a good idea because
all of a sudden the republicans will
have no one if trump dies or whatever
yeah uh well i mean that's their problem
to figure out i don't even want to give
them advice i don't don't give them any
ideas
all right i hope that they don't figure
that out i hope that whatever happens
they end up with no leader that would be
great
right um
you know i really appreciate um
because i was on the right very much so
oh and then i saw your interview with um
jessie lee peterson and
i thought wow this maybe i'm wrong and
then that can't be true is that really
the story of you being deeply um the one
you did in september i believe of last
year and my friend sent me it and you
know i was still kind of questioning my
my beliefs politically and then i saw
that and i'm like this can't be real
yeah wow well i mean okay i didn't think
that that interview achieved anything
other than comedy but that's great to
hear
yeah so just you know thank you for
setting me straight i guess pleasure
pleasure and let's hope that this thing
turns around in jersey
it'll be all right okay i don't think i
don't think he's gonna win okay all
right good good good all right roy in
south jersey great to hear from you
let's go to our friend tamisha in new
york city tamesha are you happy with
eric adams as the next mayor of new york
city
no i did not vote for him really
really who did you vote for tamisha
i voted for the teacher
i wrote a third party because i knew he
was going to win okay okay and what
don't you like about eric adams
i don't like the whole
crime
aspect where let's focus on police
because i feel like crime is a
multifaceted
thing and you have to look at
many different aspects like poverty
um education
housing all those things fit into why
crime might go up or down sure
so just looking at oh to fix crime let's
look at police alone
bothers me so that's what bothered me
about him and
i don't like his stance on teet um how
he focuses on education he's pro charter
school i'm not pro charter
fair so you just disagree you just
disagree with him on uh priorities i
guess i would say
yeah sleepo's platform was more
progressive to me but he's crazy
yeah i i can't i don't know about
characterizing it as more progressive
but he's crazy that's absolutely true
so um i know eric adams was going to win
but i'm not really too happy i wasn't
really happy with the choices
fair fair all right well we will see how
uh now if eric adams does well will you
still be pleased
of course you will okay good i figured
to me sure you've always seemed like you
have a good head on your shoulders your
son's doing okay
yes
oh there he is oh all right very good
um all right good well anything else to
mesha
not really uh just one thing um
it's weird to me that people are upset
with biden right now understandably so
with certain things but
to all take the leap to say i'm gonna
vote republican yeah do you think that's
what's happening i mean or is it just
people not showing up i think it's
people not showing up that's my instinct
but we'll know when we have more exit
polls
yeah we'll see i'm keeping my fingers
crossed but it's not looking good hey
last thing to mesha in new york city
pizza vocabulary is it logical to you
that if you say you want a regular pizza
that that's cheese or is that kind of
weird language
yeah i usually just say plain oh plain
you go with plain okay interesting
got it
all right tamisha thank you for the call
always a pleasure
thank you have a good night all right
you too there's tamisha and her son
always great to hear from them um
i want to say thank you to alexisfan13
for signing up via twitch prime if
you've not used your twitch prime
subscription this month and remember
you you get a free one if you have an
amazon prime account i would love for
you to use it here on the david pakman
show
twitch stream also want to say thanks to
david wilson for signing up on my
website with the coupon code felony21
and alan posnick
new members number 145 and 146. if
you're watching if you appreciate what
we're doing the extra streams sign up at
joinpakman.com why not
let's speak to a few other people here
um i'm going to go back to
was it was it pronounced elijah from
from virginia
yeah so it's um it's actually a legend
your name and you mispronounced it
that's rare yeah i said it right the
first time and then you sang it back uh
correctly to me
you messed it up actually yeah what
what's
my friends just call me ellie um it's
actually uh it's it's like an ancient
word it used to mean like the blessed
spirit fields but they pronounced it
elision um i actually i actually just
picked the name um my legal name is ryan
but i wanted something that was like
mask and femme so it's elijah and for
long and it's ellie for sure wow and you
legally changed your name to that
i haven't committed that hard but i've
been going by it for a couple of years
okay fair fair fair all right all right
so tell me what's happening there in
virginia other than the obvious
yeah so i mean obviously we have an
eight point victory for yunkan here if
that holds and that's just like an
absolute smashing way more than anyone
expected it is already down to six just
so you know
okay but i mean even if it was like we
know it was bad for democrats if young
kid slid by him even if it was close it
was bad for democrats we're talking
about more than five points so that's
tremendous no i did vote for princess
here i'm not sure if you're familiar
with her she's like the third party
candidate and um you know i just think i
just think they walked into it they
really did like they ran this entire i
don't know how much you've been
following it i haven't been tuning in
too much last couple of months but they
ran this entire election here on donald
trump and it was all about trump and
he's not even on the ballot anymore you
know he's not even in office anymore and
needless to say that's not a good
strategy when you don't offer anything
to people they're not going to vote for
you and i think so this is important so
you were in virginia and you were the
target of advertising you did feel that
it was a referendum on trump
yes i absolutely i mean that was every
single advertisement they sent out my
friend drew sent me my old roommate dan
from last year he sent me a mailer that
he thought was from young kin and maybe
you've seen these but it says
endorsement announcement from donald
trump and it's got glenn young kid on
the front and it looks like it's a young
kid ad but if you look in the small
script in the bottom it's paid for by
the democrats that was their all-in
strategy from the get-go was this guy
likes donald trump this guy supports
trump and young can kind of distance
himself and like i said he's not on the
ballot anymore so i'm not sure how much
of it is a turnout issue how much of it
is independence or pissed off i mean i
think it's a combination of the two wow
wow wow all right well listen i
appreciate your insights
of course thanks so much david keep up
the good work all right you too take
care
uh let's check in with jimmy from philly
uh jimmy from philly james you're on the
air what's going on
uh well a little tidbit about governor
murphy in new jersey
okay yeah mainstream media told
everybody that there was all these
curfews
for months people people were all upset
and then a couple months later good old
governor murphy with a wry smile said
there was no curfew i never ordered any
curfew
you're gonna vote for a guy like that
that deceives you by a mission
and that guy that said the suburbs of
philly yeah that that's all my friends
that move over to washington township
because they hate philadelphia they
ain't boom for that clown mm-hmm
okay all right interesting
yeah yeah yeah they all move over to
washington township because they can't
stand philadelphia they did
better for themselves
did they in what way
they made more money they they they got
they they did well in life
and they can't stand philadelphia
so they moved they moved to a suburb and
they made more money than in the city
no they did better in life better in
life but they made more money you said
right
david they don't like democratic
politicians no that but hold on i'm
actually interested in that's ridiculous
what would be an example job where one
of your friends made more money
in the suburbs of philadelphia in jersey
than in philly what's it what job pays
more well first of all the suburbs of
philadelphia is not new jersey oh i
thought you were saying this the philly
suburbs in jersey that the car
one of your callers said that and you
said that it sounds illegal yeah that
was a joke you know that was a joke
right yeah i i know it wasn't true
i understand that good a reasonable
person but he's he's being truthful
because a lot of people moved out of
philadelphia to just across the bridge
got it but so to go back i'm really
interested in job markets what is the
job your friends had who they left
to the suburbs and made it my one
friend's a trucker
the one friend's a trucker and his wife
works for uh
what does his wife do his wife makes
more money than him actually she works
for the government somewhere
i'm unsure
okay but so you got like five kids so
yeah to live in washington township with
five kids you gotta have money you gotta
have money to live anywhere david i
lived in jersey
20 years ago i used to live in this
listen to this talk show yeah and
it
they deduced that a single person 20
years ago
to live in a to live in an apartment
maintain a car had to make 44 000 a year
in new jersey
i i can only imagine what it is now
jimmy is it okay if we try to just stick
to one topic and then we'll go to the
next one sure okay so my question is
let's say you were in landscaping i
would guess
as a landscaper you make more working in
philly than in suburbs because usually
landscaping work is more expensive in
cities so i want to know hold on just
let me finish the question jimmy jimmy
jimmy i'm begging you let me finish the
question
i'm sorry
what is the type of job
where you made your friends made more
by quitting the philly job and getting
the same job in a suburb what is the job
i
the truth is david they couldn't stand
living in philly so it wasn't true when
you said they made more money when they
left they just didn't like philly
well yes that's part of it you lied you
told me something that wasn't true
okay david
next next question
i don't know jimmy you called me but so
so you're saying it's not truthful you
didn't really you don't really have an
example of that
listen david i'm on my third twelve
percent beer so i don't know what the
hell i said to you to be honest with you
okay all right
uh okay anything else jimmy anything
else i can do for you anything well you
know governor murphy is a scumbag he
allowed the mainstream media to tell
everybody in new jersey that there were
curfews he never refuted it then a
couple months later with a wry smile he
said what curfews i never ordered a
curfew
yeah i just don't know anything about
that i don't know i don't know a thing
about that that's exactly what he did
david i'm telling you the truth is this
more true than your friend who left
philly and made more in the suburbs
david
david
you got to be kidding me you're talking
about the truth i mean i'm talking to
you like
david what was that stream that you said
that you're an admitted liar and like i
have it there's a playlist on my channel
yeah anybody can access it i don't know
what you're talking about i think maybe
you were joking but you said it jimmy
what'd you have for dinner tonight
i have yeah
i had a um
i have a bag of gourmet uh microwave
stuff
now pf changs
pf changs i've never been there
it's a restaurant but they put out
gourmet i know what it is i've just
never been yeah
okay it's gourmet are you asking me what
i have for that what'd you have for
dinner what did i put there i had pha
are you familiar with pha it's a um
vietnamese soup or is it cambodian it's
cambodian right
sounds gay
all right jimmy we're gonna let you go
okay thank you there's jimmy from philly
when it goes overtly homophobic we just
kill it
um
let's see
i do want to say thank you to a bunch of
people
who just signed up via twitch prime
jose dahmedy greater candle carrickman
evan lutz music roguemaster t.m feldman
common cider and r geru
putting us at 154 for the day
also over on the website an american
hero anthony spolar just got a new
website membership with the coupon code
felony21
and his new member number 155. folks
today is the day to sign up on my
website it is imperative that we do that
we are watching results from jersey
where for now
the republican challenger is winning by
oh wait a second hold on where did that
go
winning by
0.82
0.82
let's speak to a few other people
like oh i don't know
let's go to
miles from arizona miles you're on the
air
hey
david
yes
hey um
no i was just watching the election
honestly there really wasn't much i had
to say um because i'm not in one of the
states that's voting
i guess
yeah i'm sorry i didn't really have a
question i was just i was just listening
but you were lit you were waiting to
talk to me right you were in the waiting
lobby
oh yeah
i had a question and then i forgot
i'm sorry that's okay um well listen
miles i'm soon gonna be down in your
neck of the woods in arizona i look
forward to the weather i look forward to
getting some great uh mexican food at
some particular restaurants i have
earmarked for a visit so i look forward
to being in arizona
oh nice um what what part of the state
if you don't mind me it's gonna be the
tucson area
oh my god i am in tucson now i am
attending university in tucson that's
shocking to me
yeah
no even though i live in i live in
phoenix but yeah i'm currently in tucson
but beautiful yeah you it yeah it's a
beautiful place you you hope you enjoy
it here thank you i've been many times
miles pleasure great to hear from you
there's miles from arizona people are
just calling in from everywhere let's go
to kevin from arlington virginia
arlington a key state in tonight's
election kevin what's going on
oh i'm just trying to figure out uh what
it's going to be like with republican
governor i've lived here for almost
seven years i've i've never actually
lived under a republican governor here
yeah are you what are you expecting
i don't really know i mean it's also
going to depend on what happens in the
state house and you know i'm in
arlington
very very blue area you know what we can
do locally
will maybe kind of stem some of the blow
but uh
yeah
excellent well did you have a question
or a comment
yeah i was wondering if you followed
this
pretty strange story that broke here on
friday about a
terror threat to shopping malls here in
northern virginia i didn't hear that
yeah so um on friday the way i found out
about i got a text message from my
apartment company and then i i saw this
in the news that
uh it's kind of started with fairfax
county police reporting that
there is a public security risk on
shopping malls in the area and we're
going to increase presence
very strange and then some reporting
came out that
said it was tied to isis
i did not hear that look i'm gonna have
to research that it sounds wild
yeah and of course nothing happened
and
there is some speculation out there that
this was potentially
some sort of plot to sway against early
voting you know
people on both sides were kind of taking
this up as oh this is clearly mentioned
to suede early voting democrats or it's
clearly meant to scare off republicans
who vote in person yeah but it just
disappeared quite a strange story quite
a strange story i'll look into it
great and um i got the same mailer that
elizian talked about i'm gonna email it
to you just so you can see oh please do
yeah please do i want to check that out
thank you
yeah all right very good uh there is uh
kevin just so you guys know trying to
get on
putting parentheses in front of your
name so that the name shows up at the
top of the list
means you will absolutely not be called
on it's a very obvious thing
and like seven people are doing it there
is no chance i will speak to you if
you're doing that it's just annoying
it's just a trick to get at the top okay
so that's a guarantee that we will not
speak
just for people to know
um it's like you know follow that to its
logical conclusion everyone just puts
parentheses in front of their name and
then now the order ends up being the
same right so let's let's be sensible
guys please
um let's go let's talk to some new
jersey people let's go to these are
going to be quick new jersey check-ins
get right to your point let's go to
connor from new jersey you're on the air
what is happening in new jersey i'm
scared
oh well can you hear me yes i can
uh yeah so i mean just the observation
uh for myself i'm in camden county okay
um
i've i've seen billboards of jack and
long side signs so there's a lot of
popularity with him
but
just
a reassuring thing i'm telling myself is
new jersey had record turnout of mail-in
voting
upwards of like a third of the entire
state uh had mail-in voting and i doubt
that's being counted yet so
part of me is thinking that we might be
okay
uh but you know
as it stands it's it's not looking
pretty so it's looking scary i think you
would agree
yeah yeah
all right connor from jersey thank you
so much for the call
let's go next to andrew from jersey
you're on the air what's going on
andrew from jersey you're on the air
hello hello
can you hear me
yes okay awesome uh yes so i actually
live in mercer which is like a pretty uh
blue canyon it has trend in it i think
they're only reporting 30 percent of
votes right now right which would
um
are the can says i think like just
being in like my local facebook group a
big reason that people are voting for uh
cinderelly is because of like school
board policies and stuff like that oh
boy you know that yeah they just get you
know galvanized by garbage that they're
hearing from you know like trump
republicans and stuff like so in a sense
similar to what some of the people are
saying in um
uh virginia
yeah yeah exactly and i see it like i'm
in the lawrence facebook group which is
part of mercer and that's just like
it's just mostly old people or people
who have kids you know wonder about the
community
and they're the ones who are just you
know you see ludicrous opinions just
about different things that aren't real
in regards to education right and
they're definitely yeah well it's
recognized it's weaponized
disinformation is what i would call it
yeah no very accurate and really see
some like horrible things coming out of
these people's mouths and right and
right in the face of everyone in the
community well we'll certainly have time
to postgame it that's for sure
yeah
all right andrew from jersey thank you
reviews are in for jimmy from philly's
phone call just got a message from a
friend who says jimmy from philly is a
comedic genius
uh i i unintentionally so i i do agree
with that let's keep going through our
tour of jersey just a little bit more
then we're going to go elsewhere in the
country let's go to ben from jersey ben
you're on the air what do you think is
going to happen in jersey here
i don't know but i'm getting a little
nervous i'm not going to lie i mean
we're now at 55
reporting and chattarelli's lead is just
a hair under two points
yeah i'm in south jersey i'm in
gloucester county um
because my college so far that's plus
nine chaturelli and that's basically it
it's it's almost 100 in so that's a red
county
yeah it is it's
south jersey is very rural and on my
college campus um they put up like a
thing that said like why do you vote and
you could put like post-it notes on it
yep and a majority of them were like
let's go brandon and like
our gas taxes are too high and
phil murphy is a liberal and it's just
like
i thought college campuses were supposed
to be progressive
i'm looking now on google maps at
gloucester county jersey so it looks
like you've got it's just mostly farms
but you've got some towns like is
glassboro the big town
yeah glassboro is where i am it's where
uh rowan university is oh i see let's
see what the down is the what's the is
the area by the courtyard by marriott is
that downtown or is that just kind of
like a yeah that's that's on rowan
boulevard which because it's a college
town so like the town is kind of built
around oh like
a school i'm literally right across the
street from the courtyard marriott right
now it doesn't look terrible but it
doesn't look great have you ever been to
oishi ramen
yes i live above it it seems well okay
dude so please uh don't
i don't want you putting yourself in any
kind of danger but oh true do they have
any miso broth that is you think
appropriate
uh
yes but at the same time
it's
kind i always get the impression when
i'm there
that it's like
a chinese restaurant masquerading as a
japanese place like it doesn't feel
super authentic oh boy we
yeah there are better japanese places in
glasgow that you can go okay okay if i
ever am there i'll i'll let you know by
the way is it weird that of the entire
country i somehow zoomed in on the
building in which you live randomly just
looking at restaurants
probably not because i i if you're
looking on google maps i mean they like
highlight like restaurants or things to
do in the towns no it's not surprising
okay and also like
the the town is just rowan so okay there
isn't much else to see got it got it got
it got it okay all right thank you my
friend i appreciate the call
thank you all right there it is
wow what a day guys what a day i want to
say thanks to camera tagis and you
taught me eight
um
for signing up via twitch prime members
156 and 157 today really appreciate that
let's speak to a few other people
because think this is quite a wild night
it's really a wild night
um what else looks interesting here
a lot of people from virginia and jersey
are calling in but we've spoken to many
of them already
let's see if we can just find something
a little different just a little
different oh let's go to leanne from
what is rva is that richmond virginia is
that code for richmond virginia
yes it is wow all right is that i didn't
know that's so that's the hip way you
call it rva
clay okay what's going on
um
well it's it's a devastating night um i
worked on uh mcauliffe's campaign in
2013.
and i felt like the energy just wasn't
there for this campaign okay and i got i
got door knocks from yonkin's campaign
multiple times even though i told them
to stop so um junk and signs were really
big all over the place
so and i think terry mcauliffe made a
couple of um pretty big gaffes oh really
what were they
well um he made you know he started he
said
in one of the debates that um
he you know that that uh
a parent should not tell kids
what you know how to uh you know well
parents shouldn't tell kids how to well
parents
couldn't tell schools oh tell schools
right
yep couldn't tell schools what to do and
so within minutes of saying that um
young can capitalize on it and made it a
a real big talking point right and then
terry tried to come back
with um you know saying that he was
taking his words out of context
and then you know they use some talking
points about what terry had done with
schools but you know he was he was
really good with schools and you know
they're using the charter schools as a
talking point for the republicans so
that's what yunkan's going to do and it
seemed to work because a ton of the
people being interviewed who said they
voted young and said their big issue was
education and crt
exactly and and you know there is no crt
taught
urgent schools that's the crazy thing
it's it's wild that that it's it just
doesn't make any sense it so basically
you're saying the propaganda worked
really well
propaganda worked really well and um he
had a bunch of yunkan had a bunch of
really young energized
um kids working on his i mean kids you
know maybe late you know late teens
early 20s just very energetic
and terry just didn't seem to have the
energy
do you like living in richmond
i love living in richmond yeah i don't
know
and i i work you know no so the other
thing is about
virginia being an absolute bell weather
for
2022 i'm not so sure about that because
every year
that um you know so so so
this will be the um
when the republicans win
you know presidential elections the the
opposite party always wins with the
exception of 2013 which is when terry
did win the governor right so it's it's
not always you know it
usually it is the opposite party that
wins so
right
all right very good leanne let's hope
for the best next year i guess we would
say yeah i'm gonna get more people out
there volunteering yeah okay thanks
david thanks leon yep pleasure
uh there's leanne from richmond virginia
we have a lot going on folks we just
have a hype train that started on twitch
and it would we should really try to win
it we haven't won one for a while i want
to say thanks to rhinodactyl eternal tns
and dragonfly back home for the twitch
subs putting us at 160. we've lost i
think about 50 of these hype trains in a
row let's try to win one
i also want to say thanks to anthony
spolar who sent a very generous 50 super
chat and says i just became a member i
enjoyed listening to you what do you
think of nikola tesla's warden cliff
tower design of generating electricity
by use of the ionosphere could be a
great alternative to fossil fuel energy
i i have to admit i'm not familiar with
that and one of my um principles that i
abide by on this program is if i don't
know about something
i don't want to comment on it the
comment below says it's pseudoscience
now i don't know if that's a reference
to
the warden cliff tower design
i genuinely don't know
but that's a very aggressive statement
to make that's for sure
welcome to everybody coming in from
trihex
hex
we will one of these days get dinner uh
oh terry mcauliffe speaking let's listen
to count the votes because every single
virginian
[Applause]
trihex viewers were doing election
results
let me first of all i want to thank
everybody here with us tonight it has
been a great campaign is he conceding in
328 days ago
i have done an average of seven to ten
events a day for the last 328 days
are terry's lips purple anybody seeing
that
and we opened up this campaign
when i kicked off this campaign down in
richmond with my great co-chairs levar
stoney and
louise lucas and charnell herring to
talk about how we needed to rebuild all
of our schools here in the commonwealth
of virginia and raise teacher pay and
get every child access to a pre-k
education and to get everybody access to
broadband here in the commonwealth of
virginia
and we have continued to take that fight
throughout this commonwealth but first
of all i want to thank my family i want
to start by thinking
i want to thank my wife dorothy
as you know she has been a champion a
true policy expert
and through her references you know 13
million more meals served in needy
children here in the camera
and i want to thank
my family
you know you don't get to pick your
parents as you know
you're born in the family and they have
survived campaign after campaign and i
want to thank dory who was here with me
tonight with her fiance nick who's here
with us tonight
wow
jack mcauliffe who is here with his
fiance shannon tonight
sally mccollum
[Applause]
and peter mccollum
[Applause]
so let's go let's count all these votes
but let me
thank each and every one of you over the
course of the last 11 months
for the doors that you've knocked down
the phone calls that you made just last
weekend 450 000 doors knocked on 2
million during the course of this
campaign i want to thank you
the mcauliffe family loves each and
every one of you thank you for watching
and i want to thank my campaign staff
it was the greatest has he said i
concede i don't know that he did
all the great work
but folks if i said long ago this is a
different state
when ralph and i were elected eight
years ago we have made our state open
and welcoming but the fight continues we
got to make sure we protect women's
right to choose here in the camera
welcome agent
we got to make sure everybody gets
quality affordable health care here in
the commonwealth of virginia everybody's
entitled to a world-class education here
in the commonwealth of virginia and we
are going to continue that fight tonight
and every day going forward so i just
want to thank all of you for what you
have meant to us i look around this room
and i see so many friends we've worked
in for many years this is a different
state we are the greatest state in the
united states of america and it's
because of you thank you god bless you
and let's go on and forward thank you
well that is the type of it's very
interesting decision he went out early
went out before glenn young went out
there oh no he's dancing hopefully
claire try to declare some form of
victory they're still counting the votes
it's still counting the votes but that's
also a signal to the supporters you can
go home now that's right and he talked
about his campaign and we okay so um
that's happening that's happening
uh and we are going to be standing by
for the eventual results from new jersey
all right folks this is going to
conclude my coverage for tonight
we are
uh
virginia's lost
we're watching jersey and we may not
know until tomorrow we are also standing
by
for news from boston
where michelle wu continues to lead and
it's looking increasingly good for her
as well so we're going to have
wall-to-wall coverage on the podcast
tomorrow
that's going to do it for my coverage
tonight we'll be back with a new podcast
tomorrow youtube clips tv show radio
show
and live kyle ritton house trial all of
those things happening tomorrow
uh i appreciate everybody who
tried to call in and we spoke to many
many people
and we're gonna be back real soon thanks
for joining me
uh
i guess that's it i don't know yes i'm
keeping them i have a mustache that is
my sign off i have a mustache thank you
almond shack